ce suivre mathieu helle grande des
finales elle à l'aspi championship et et
2020 je sais pas dire en espagnol donc
on est mal dormi l'humanité barcelona
lionel messi diego
j'adore diego mais j'ai vu que les
barcelonais n'ont avant les billets tout
mais c'est vieux je parle pas très bien
tu parles pas très bien à l'époque l'om
à nancy
ces coups c'est quand même que tu nous
mais là c'est en fait c'est parce que
sur les trucs officielle il ya le ya le
replay du vrai life et donc je pense
qu'ils font douter ils ont ils ont dans
un genre de best of
enfin bon c'est pas des athlètes 1 c'est
pas des huit villes de larges quoi tagro
benghazi avec les coques elle est juste
office chinois
c'est ludique de larges production quoi
je vais juste me best-of cc libye nexway
libye avec son chapeau c'est au dessus
de tout non enfin je veux juste vérifier
qu'on soit bien la haine parce que je ne
vois pas et j'aime bien et j'aime bien
voir en fait il m'a fallu les tontons à
saillé ali chaïbou james webb mais je
veux quand même vérifier et donc du coup
tu vas nous expliquer le format parce
que je crois c'est la 1er le premier
speech est ce que je commande de stoner
il ya des années j'avais commenté plus
oui oui il y avait des années ouais tu
avais plus commenter parce que j'ai
beaucoup de speechless écho plus j'ai
envie de dire mais alors le format c'est
simple une heure trente de 5 + 1 n'a
comme une heure de 3 + 1 30 minutes 2 1
+ 1 et hier est ce qu'il ya du random au
milieu comme avant bas c'est fini ça ils
ont arrêté ma trop bien pour sow
mais juste avec c'est bizarre tu dis
c'est bizarre ouais mais c'est le fameux
débat le mec qui embarrasse là dessus
mais par exemple est ce que c'est normal
qu'un titre de champion du monde deux
parties clés 6 juin rapide pour moi oui
oui rien on est là là je suis d'accord
avec toi championnat du monde de glisse
le mec il ya une rom d'homme n'était pas
le même jeu toi oui et non c'est sûr ça
dure c'est sûr on est on est 200 %
d'accord on est 200 % d'accord donc
ouais donc je suis pas surpris après
c'était juste rigolo parce qu'on pouvait
voir des partis c'est une importe quoi
mais dans l'absolu c'est pas normal non
mais ils ont bien fait de langue et puis
ça faisait durer les matchs une demi
heure de plus au final et à 3h45 avec
les pauses 3h30 de jeu effectif
3h30 carey tu me connais en trois heures
de jeu par donc trois heures ça dure
trois heures et demie en tout et
j'espère est moins bon que tu veux la
vie et pour les candidats ailleurs sinon
j'ai lu stores de 11h aussi à plusieurs
endroits mais franchement je suis pas
sûr juste on en a parlé ensemble
l'homme est d'ailleurs on en a parlé
ensemble mais par an ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il ya un changement d'heure
pendant le temps des agents suis sûr il
y aura pas de changement d'heure en
russie donc mais par contre ce sera à
midi je pense soltren j'ai vérifié ça
ouais c'est censé réduire mais après je
croyais que ekatérinbourg c'était sur un
créneau horaire avec une demie à verre
en demi heure en fait ce qu en russie
sont aussi des créneaux horaires avec
des demi heure comme en iran ouais c'est
un peu bizarre mais ça s'explique par la
grandeur du pays
il m'a rappelé mon élève qui dit du coup
il ya comme un décalage établi trois
heures et demie quoi se dire que c'est
quoi le smic est bluffé complètement
du coup à la russie c'est le pays au
monde où il ya le plus de fuseaux
horaires moi ça me ferait il est quand
même hein c'est là sa part de
kaliningrad nom qui n'est pas loin de
chez dédé justement kaliningrad
ouais et ça va jusqu'à vladivostok qui
est plus à l'est que la chine en fait
foi sa compteront la chine
en fait non c'est énorme comme pays la
russie
on se rend pas compte non non non se
rend pas compte
c'est même quand ils habitent en réalité
tu te rends tu t'en as pas contre c'est
trop gros mais là où tu t'en monde sait
que quand tu dois aller par la cantine
dessus que tashi pas combien d'heures de
vol de moscou avait pourtant c'est pas
loin de moscou
ah on me laissait c'est ça qui te fait
dire qu'il n'ya qu'un intrus qui oui oui
c'est un truc qui fera quoi exactement
ce que je t'ai lenstra en australie
j'avais des potes là-bas immunisés ils
étaient venus en europe et pour eux tout
était proche mais quand pour proche des
genres paris tu vas au fin fond de des
pays de l'est pour eux cette époque qu
en voiture quand ils allaient d'une vue
d une ville des fous en australie mais
étaient douze heures de voiture
oui oui mais c'est des trucs comme ça on
se rend pas compte
non non russie te dise où ils vont pas
je suis en france bon j'ai peut-être
faire un saut en norvège pas sa joie
c'est sur la route
ainsi christophe ils disent que nous
sommes partout attendant on va voir il
donne 49 % 51 pour n'a qu'à moi j'aurais
mis 55 45
il a battu un seul à la fois c'est la
caricature est attendri c'est quoi leur
pronostiquant un peu un souhait
largement de vous 5
attends je comprends que 3 2 6 7
annoncés le rex et il est numéro 1 il
est le meilleur en cinq plus un meilleur
endroit plus sain et un engagement tout
ils ont dû faire les
les scores
de tous les chaises avec la moyenne et
l'eau j'en sais rien et tu as vu ce truc
redjam d'ailleurs qui est plus ou moins
le sponsor de la finale pas du tout
c'est un échiquier extraordinaire
mathieu est là pour la peine
je sens encore bien plus mais c'est une
pub complètement sincère base edwards
les pièces bouche tout seul en réalité
pour les blancs et les noirs genre tu
joues sur ton ordi est à l'échiquier qui
touche tout seul c'est vraiment bien et
j'ai un agent d'autres comme france et
bientôt franchement ça vaut le coup d'en
discuter avec fab et rémy a mis un set à
dès sa découverte j'ai découvert réunir
avec l'été qui est fait qu'ils étaient
allons en rugby très bons joueurs de
coin est un très bon joueur de nounous
balaye sont ils sont en ce moment ils
sont plutôt pas mal à la belote avec
fabre allemagne qui alliait rémunérés
mais à cause d'une partie où ils ont
perdu sont en très mauvaise part car ils
ont fait 2000 à 110 web aller ils sont
pris que des j'aime pas trop là les
pièces faux l'échiquier beau mais les
pierres je suis pas coup mais le conte
le concept et chants mais non choix du
design mais le concept en soi
ils ont nulle rex et ses classes tessa
fait penser aux premiers échiquiers sont
en 3d que tu avais été son lord et tu
pourrais me placer des pièces comme ça
on me dit j'ai peur du prix dans le chat
alors avec fabre et une discussion avec
faber et libon rémi duval ht par litre
est chaud parce qu'il a des escape game
nom qui va être super classe dans les
styles km mais il est là un super
d'ailleurs il l'avait avec mazet oui la
mode à montpellier et d'ailleurs si je
vous conseille d'y aller si vous êtes
sur montpellier il ya la salle qu'ils
appellent psychose les normes il ya
quatre phrases il ya un truc sur un
scénario à la game of thrones oui oui un
scénario avec un avec des échecs dont
qui pensait le prendre il a dit qu'il le
prenait jusqu'à 300 euros
moi je monte à 41 encore c'est ça qui
veut dire les prix sort dans deux jours
et demi donc
mais moi je vais prendre milan
kickstarter à 300 à 400 euros je le
prends ça marche vraiment bien bassin
kickstarter donc il n'est pas il
n'existe pas encore ouais non c'est vrai
nom ne pas rendre le conseil c'est sûr
que c'est rigolo dans là que c'est parti
de là première partie est parti et à
wesley qui aller choper un pion b de
mathieu c'est théorique il ya une partie
libye mazet il ya quinze ans le palais
nombreuses ne portent pas prier mazet
prier libye pas vous ce qui est lointain
fait nul à ça fait du turbin taurin
genre milliers de jeux pour le gain il
ya un service de dames tu peux jouer à
temps je me rappelle comment tu tiens il
ya une idée pour jeu pour le guen tu
peux gagner la dame
comment ça peut marcher
non mais pour qui dort on n'a pas parlé
de ça avec un petit short b1
je pense que ça d'un prend d'hommes c1
et les noirs comment non non tu d'un mât
de dames siens il sait lire coup là
mathieu à ses parts coût par passager
alors surtout à partir pas cette
position incroyable cardinalice et des
lycéens
et après tu donnes la dame je ne sais
pas j'aurai à 6
je veux dire apprend b tu fais un truc
comme ça alors ça c'est intéressant
hikaru jeu des trucs à que lui sortir
qui joue je sais pas si tu avais vu
j'avais suivi un peu un de ces
speechless et s'il perd intéressant il
joue à 5 très vite
oui et on va très vite il faut un truc
keller perdant mais en fait il a hyper
bien analysé qu'elle est déjà arrivé
c'est ça faut à cette fougue et 6 soit
là il n'y a que lui qui peut être la
vôtre duda il y avait une partie très
bizarre et ouais parce que j'avais
commencé à regarder puisque c'est
intéressant et surtout que l'autre a dû
préparer quelque chose oui la séance
c'est quand même la finale là mathieu et
c'est vrai que à mon avis autant tu sais
en quarts de finale match reims encore
un peu amicale et tout autant là je
pense que les deux ont vraiment envie de
gagner c'est enfin tu prends quand même
un titre
quoi qu'il en soit
non mais bon on puisse y ait de la thune
et en plus pas récent américains tous
les deux il ya un peu de talent d'avoir
un peu d'orgueil oui oui normand ça a
été un match chaud à la fin un parti non
oui oui parce que ça ok ça donne quoi ça
on nous dit on déteste tous ceux-là ils
sont tous pour moi je vais mettre à
l'encontre du chat j'ai envie de voir un
acteur et chine ont protesté je sais pas
pourquoi il était contre nous dès qu'il
mettait un commentaire après je pense
qu'il fait même pas exprès juste il
n'est même pas nos positions
oui mais bon après du coup il s'était
trop le par maxime parent nous puis ça
et il est rentré dans le jeu mais
honnêtement j'ai envie de voir un hack a
chuté tu vois 15h05 la peine carl f 5 1
le premier de ces positions qui aiment
blanc sexy dance fientes c'est pas trop
le m skf 4g 5h si c'est pas une case d2
où les fous 3.4 peut être faible et tu
peux pas lire dans ces hommes ce que tu
as tout rires ah là tu peux mais oui va
assez tristounet et les noirs ils
veulent jouer vite tour 8 joue au centre
après il faut faire gaffe défaut de par
contre vous prend à achille des nains
kf5 reprend un cheese m2 et une bourse
attaque ce que du compte pas envoyer
c'est d'envoyer mouais mais j'ai le
droit de bouger mon roi pour voir des
cayes g8 c'est ce que je retiens les
leçons qui peut menacer quel projet 7
aussi afin que j'allais mans d2 pourquoi
que je veux faire mais ça ça remette lui
là et faire ça mais tu auras je suis 3g
g8 même ça ça marcherait pas bien aïda
me suis là ça c'est intéressant
alors c'est quoi la différence c'est que
tu gardes l'intégrale fermé et que je
sais pas tu te libères un peu la lame
non bal adam tu fais tu de la libère
pour la gazzetta mais il ya aussi des
coupes supplémentaires
ouais bon courage et 4 c'est déjà trop
tard
là c'est pour ça que je lis sur huit
îles away dame f3 d'un bertrand balas
toujours qui est prêt un chiffre sans
égal et d'accessoires
j'aime bien les blancs et coûte quand
même avec c'est une position bizarre
intacte aura 5 pts est une idée en date
de défense ouais ouais mais à quatre
dames et franc mais à celui de carénage
6 non justement s'il fait ici tu dois
jouer sauf cavaliers h cents
pour roy sinon tu peux bouger le roi
ptolémée cachette d'un match 5
tu vois comment ça m'est resté flou
prendra fin qu'à l'étranger cette machin
ou achètent ouais donc c'était l'autre
option non une dame f3 et vosges aux
cavaliers g8 peut-être d'un f3 et
menaces qui reprend h6 toujours après ce
genre de position des fois les noëls
dans une idée pas mal mais d'ailleurs ça
peut marcher avec les blancs dans
l'autre sens c'est bon il ya des
italiennes ou ses débuts les noirs qui
amène un cavalier à 9,4 et du coup il ya
une idée pas mal c'est le matin camille
et ange et un manque dans ces cas-là en
g8
ouais on se détache au roi et après tu
veux bouger le cas l'autre cavaliers
faire j'ai six mois les jantes et 5 g 6
par exemple et après veut en fait quand
tu chasses tout petit peu là je pense
qu'il va faire cailler g8 s'il n'y a pas
de tactique et g8 il faut quand même
vérifiez toujours ça mais ensemble
pourquoi ça marche non ça m'a fait
remarquer vas-y tu continues à noter que
vous prend 1,6 aussi ça peut être
dangereux sa mâture oui il a fait kg 8
donc peut-être l'étranger cette jouable
je serais vraiment incroyable parce
qu'après je sais maintenant très belle
partie qui est plongé cette foule
prendre les cas je pense que c'est ça
qui l'a vu très sûrement c'est fort ça
refroidit or froid dire batwa un petit
défaut d'avoir me suis là donc là je
veux menacé keichi ils menacent
maintenant genre vraiment ce que tu lui
ouais bon son idée parce que si ces
quelques averses en gamme jet set matin
ouais comme ça il n'empêche et peut-être
tour trois tours j'ai trois genres
oui c'est un peu too much genre la tour
soit ne crée pas assez de menaces et
c'est un peu too much le hockey h 4 h 5
ou 6000 tours 1 8 pts
il pouvait jouer bon pour le monde
d'avoir et planète et pourquoi pas
arracher quatre ici mais le succès cinq
jeux 6 il a fait en tout cas il a fait
allez bon il écoute le strip les
cavaliers aux cinq fermes à rendre tout
à l'heure c'est à la place de 2 km 6 à 8
au regard des besoins si ça marche pour
un 8 sur tf1 à chis voulait prendre
angers 4 f5 pas mal d'années en marche
et ça a marché
donc il a fait cas f6 damev 3 kg 8 h 4
donc maintenant il veut h5 dame g3 en
gros et cavaliers 5 yves dame g3 je
pense et j'ai 6 en fait je me demande
est ce qu'un truc comme ça ça peut
j'aurais dit dame en h cup ce temps les
dix dames fkbp52 f4 pour avoir menacé si
ce bon il a fessé 5 mars et le concret
en gros il veut pas laisser les
cavaliers en vie sur f5
non quand m après cavalier e 5 son idée
ça sera peut-être un jour quel sens un
jesse ces quatre cas les détroits bref
ou y arriver au getty cavaliers 5
d'amérique attaquer les t3 d'ailleurs on
n'avait pas vu oui donc c'était plutôt
donnerait plutôt tamm ha tamm e313 mais
du coup maintenant sur cavalier e 5
dames d un beauf et à manger trois
thèmes par vraiment g6 je peux pas non
camaïeu 5 je vois pas pourquoi il le
fait par ya forcément une raison
ce qu'il est en train de perdre beaucoup
de temps hikaru forcément quelque chose
qui le jaune
wade a joué bien le vrai je vois pas
honnêtement je vois pas le problème
bon après possible à jouer stratégique
ces dames des as qui avait lieu 3 jouer
la case des singles je n'aurais cap des
3 qui va compenser pour le mans et quand
je vais je sais 4 après je mettrai mon
fiancé 5,1 millions c4 a peut-être
faible à l'heure actuelle je suis dawn
of the screen menaces et je peux vouloir
bloquer le 3 qui est des cinq et en
créer une autre et après fouille trois
cas si je fais mon dames 2 admettons
bizarre bon mais il veut cavaliers 3 qui
est des cinq fauves où j'ai tourné en
gros c'est simplement saison de coups je
le fait que bien sûr ça marche mais
j'aime pas trop ce genre de coups par
principe je préfère largement les plans
ici mathieu c'est parce que toi
d'enfance oui pour moi c'était
stratégiquement c'est terrible on coupe
moi ce que j'aurais bien comme scénario
dans ce match va savoir ceux qui
débutent et 1 + 1 à +3 profond ce serait
le rêve genre n'a qu'a tu vois la course
qui doit rattraper trois points en
bullet et ça peut donner une fin de
match de feu en fait ouais là là je
pense que c'est le joueur américain qui
en train de prendre le dessus mathieu
les deux sont américains oui je sais
c'est pour ça que ce qui a aidé 4k et
des cinq banques et des cartilages
hawkeye g8 7
mais franchement mais et yak et prend
ses cartes mature sur la route des cinq
d'abord et tu veux qu'elle ait des 5
il n'y a pas que se tient fourchette
ouais il va il va jouer je pense on voit
on va plus trop toucher les pièces
mathieu jurés agréable et la jouer à
quatre voix il a joué à quatre
intermédiaires
je veux dire et là il ya des chiens à 5
en l'air à 5t penchard m dames seules
sept étoiles par aqmi il veut pas de
l'attaqué d'une autre façon c'est chaud
chasse qui est difficile si t'es pas un
athlète comme os l'eso dans cette
position c'est de finir là kakavand
parce que le gars tu ajoutes ou tempo
sur ces 8 c'est bien joué il veut
bloquer le kmf 4 il avait bien vu à lci
là il a plus de gaz qui
j'ai quelques jeux cas ici six mois et
non là ça fait mal maintenant il a dû
partir durant la semaine
as-tu menace quand même il ay london
irish cat qui est pas de coups gagnants
laquelle beckham du côté de jeunes
auraient peut-être cinq cavaliers chien
qui veut faire je pense que la ferté les
dessins qui échanger un cavalier et
jouer la colonne non j'ai pas pensé mais
c'est d'avoir raison enfin ça a l'air
fort du mois mais c'est hyper tenteront
de faire aussi négocié ce qu'un quart
élèves 3 intéressant il veut faire 5 en
force
fais gaffe à trois mais quatre dames à 7
mai la forêt mais je pensais seulement
pas du tout il n'y a pas un roi qui part
en g3 l'agent roy scheider où l on les
fait un cahier h55 et h57 et j'ai trois
matches qui arrivent et j'ai cinq échecs
wakai prend 4 bien jouer basque et j'ai
trois mannequins mais ça marchait aussi
sur vos f1 oui c'est monstrueux mais kg
tu peux pas y a plus on prend et
abandonne oui peut-être je dois faire
damrau quatre filets la dame et perdre
sutil et fornaka truc de ouf
il fait bien en main qu'un ces machins
le plus yelp yongbin pion à arriver à
temps c'est pas fini qui avait d'un
première fois ma prime 3 c'est fini
puzzle rechute mais le cavalier prend 4
mathieu attrayant il y avait deux points
chacun
y'a pas là comme des joueurs et elle est
partie désolé merci de nous l'avoir dit
elle y était mais ça bug de chez buggé
ouais je vais je vais essayer les gars
je promets rien omis dame accélérée d'un
coup il a changé deux premiers coups a
nantes il a choisi le deuxième combat
c'est pas pourquoi elle se remet pas je
vais tenter voilà ça sert me est donc là
la mode c'est de jeu ses positions avec
un fond le 2b 3 kg 2 mais ils font eux
deux tu attendes b5 pour faire un cadre
qui a et b 3 mais je vais enrober pas de
la partie précédente là mathieu qu'est
ce qu'est ce qui s'est passé là pour
wesley
en kf3 mou du genou et il s'est pris ce
tour bekhadda mince est un peu naïf
ouais qu'est ce que le cavalier des cinq
ans mais moi il fallait peut-être faire
qualité 5
je vais un peu plus actif d'un meeting
jeter spoilé l'ouverture can wait
aspoise française pas franchement tu as
boyle mais ça va donc pour les noirs ça
doit pas être plaint un peu moins bien
qu'à détroit il ya des belles parties de
frais cinema club a bien joué oui il a
mis parti comme ça de près de fêter ses
quatre malfrats défaut à trois ça
égalise pas ça normalement
enfin il faut être hyper précis je sais
que quelqu'un comme romain je vais je
veux utiliser les pats égalisant pro
chess ligne dans une partie avec un truc
pareil c'est possible - n'y avait pas
une partie était comme ça genre un peu
mal est en réalité ils avaient les mêmes
pas souffert 1,5
c'était bien je sens qu'elle et ses
quatre avaient faux insiste intéressant
de voir un joueur du calibre de wesley
so un défenseur de son calibre jouer ça
quand ma cave trouve mais pour moi c'est
un mauvais choix
thd peut-être pour menacer des idées qui
c'est qu'a t il sur fond assis sur un
détour prend 17 mai masqué prend b6
calme une fois ci ce n'était pas sûr de
saisine x 6 x 6
c'est ça je n'étais pas sûr c'est
compliqué ouais peut-être fut battu
tours d un peut-être journée un way et
puis tu fais ton c'est un fouet f3 mais
tour d un des 5 quel point ça ne marche
pas moi puisque je vais montrer joulin
sitôt prendre cette démarche mais quel
point 5 e b 4 en attaque des cavaliers
c6 y ses soirées au quesnoy y voit qu'on
sait que les blancs étaient un peu mieux
en pratique il c'est parti ça ouais
c'est la partie gâteau revient en a dit
ce qu'elle promet s'ils souffrent les
deux
peut-être toro et aux menaces qu'elle
prend 17 français 5
ce que je gagne pas un pion après c'est
un seul coup leur oppose
c'est la partie ouais c'est un lyon plus
de plus pour tourner à cas tu sais que
ça peut être un tournant du match déjà
cette première partie mathieu non ce
grave
ouais ouais mais très mauvais choix
d'ouverture
non mais celle d'avant so il a juste
très bien joué jusqu'au venez ça fait
mal hein dans des matchs serrés comme ça
[Musique]
à l'air hyper concentré d'habitude il
fait beaucoup plus le troll oui donc ça
je pensais que c'était le bon coup pour
jouer le photocall de raposo enfin la
tenir a quand même tu sais d'ailleurs
qu'on joue contre l'équipe ii n'a qu'à
le 4 mars à 19 heures on compte cette
ligue 1 8e de finale france new york pas
si t'es au courant si si mais je pense
que je jouais pas mais je ne m'arrête
pas à temps à quel point 8 regarde ton
reprendre tour c'est un tort c'est 8
tout haut des seins ça va arriver en
face on y est en train de jouer sur ces
8 euros de se roder 8c france et 5 et
sur un autre coup je peux prendre 17 et
voyez là où quand on va voir un
footballeur brieuc c'est cette fois il
va jouer le clouage éternel mais tu dire
si je défends des six mais quand tu
défends de laurent d641 une forte c'est
toi ouais mais sa frappe coup imposer
encore où je veux mais tu vas commentée
par contre le 8e de finale c'est le 4
way a tenté été chaud thé chaud des
choses de knight pour ce match et
mathieu ouais il faut ainsi je suis là
en train de regarder la nasa à temps
mathieu ses shows de nike ce match
france aux états unis et elle n'a cassé
c'est l'affiché rêvée mercredi quatre
sont normalement second
attends ça va être mathieu on a fait
toute la saison pour ça quand même non
les codes français les coqs français -
il va y avoir il va y avoir quatre
coques face à face à 4/4 aux dogues
ce que c'est quoi une équipe adverse
n'accueille qu'un café de ces iem
gousseïnov morandat c'est pas mal mais
oui mais bon c'est en dessous de mvl je
vais pas se coller la compo mais pas qui
jouera bastiani fini à vendre n'importe
que 2 0 mathieu le joueur le joueur
d'origine philippine en surface face au
joueur d'origine japonaise assez
intéressant de voir ce qu'il va jouer
sur ça parce que c'est mon répertoire à
ecublens quand même vous êtes cinq ans
mais aussi moments importants mais j'ose
dire oui j'ai déjà joué cette position
entre bitstream c'était vraiment très
très instructif je pense pouvoir tenir
assez facilement contrôler wesley un
petit rock c'est pas le coup le plus mal
mais c'est un seul marrant c'est que
c'est pas qu'on nomme deux tu penses pas
on a ces qualités 5la faut jamais ça en
fait j'ai toujours considéré que c'était
bien pour les vents bat et là je crois
que le bon coup se nomme en fait ça
dépend s'était intercalé à schifflange
que tout vrai voilà pourquoi dam des
trois donnent davantage ici et ouais
j'avais déjà joué comme ça mais bon
ouais ça va poindre dans le 7 juin
peut-être avec cette horde savard est
même peut-être donne des trois est en
fait tu peux avoir la même avec les
pions à 85 et ça diffère et il ya aussi
des différentes avec hsh quatre noms la
dame de deux je crois que c'est bien
jouer si tu avais mis à chis faux h 4 ko
prend 1,4 et donc c'est pour ça que ce
soir de cours - étaient censés une été
mieux pour les messies ferris eastman
mais là je vais bon match 4g genre
flotteront alors suivant h4 qui apprend
le 4 cos et ça vous prend des huit qui
est pro d2 c'est un truc qui est connu
et donc c'est pour ça que moi que les
morts je pense que ces mesures-là
schiste faut à scott maintenant mais
jean rouger 5 h 6 e direct ouais faut hk
troc eu deux bons lors de colle un peu
bizarre même cahier des quatre issifou
tu peux pas vu d'un des deux donc le
coup ces dames détroit mais du coup
c'est une sorte de petite concession ce
que c'est quand même pas la kasbah
testud tu fais tu bloques quoi on
retournera parce qu il ya une partie par
un peu une belle nul entre nataf et
frais signer un top 12 ya quelques
années je rappelle la partie de vlad
avec les blancs aux 7es championnats
d'europe par équipe de france contre
l'espagne
ah oui c'est fait comme nous adhérons
ouais mais tu sais que c'est horrible
parce que il arrange la ligne il s'était
juste part rappelé il a rejoué contre
moi et j'ai perdu au change pas je pense
qu'on trouve là bas il ne se rappelait
plus non mais ils connaissaient pas je
crois il manie ouais mais contre moi ils
connaissent
oui qu'on doit payer connaissait mais
était très mécontent qu'on ne l'ait pas
dit je sais pas qui lui aurait dit quoi
mais mais ça pour moi c'est
théoriquement c'est le point blanc après
ça reste une partie d'échecs l'image de
pour ces six des 5
gfr et si tu joues pour des six des
jouets jouer f3 g4 ça j'en ai gagné des
partis avec ce plan grand froid j'ai
également beaucoup mieux pour les blancs
la f3 je pense ouais bon petit coin 3 à
pour cobo faut deux jeux parisiens
blindés ou quatre semaines développer
nos mères froisser nos mains mais en
fait je sais pas où il va aller 2-5
c'est nantes 1 kg cathy le jeu de 9,4 à
manger sain après je demande est ce
qu'on a besoin de s'embêter avec un fou
comme ça bah si sa guidance et oui mais
bon fallait apparemment il ne sait pas
quoi faire après tout huit donc où ces 4
6 4 kg catherine foucher 4 kg 4 bref
cette non ouais c'est ça je regardais
mais après je reviendrai m6
il y aura 17 ans présents non puisqu'on
dit à quel point ouais bon peu importe
il a fait avec 4 il a fait f4 oui c'est
vrai que sur des systèmes nas trinquet
north écroué non je peux bouger la dame
j'ordonne eu la partie moins il vient de
faire des six franchement on dit tous
les couvents je sais pas j'ai pas dit de
toulouse mathieu mais il est temps aussi
où ces deux questions sur d'un match 3
des sprints cela va peut-être faire des
cavaliers ou 4 je pense que la finale et
prochain ce sera ce sera mardi quand des
temps je pense il maintiendra sur
maintient ce niveau de jeu senna caïsso
qui court entre on coiffe ou very well
played by the french players sait si
j'ai peu joué ces six qualité sept cas
et décès de sa méthode d'un âge 3 non
ouais damages croix et tu vas peut-être
forcée si c'est une viande et 3,22 qu'on
décide d'apprendre à oui c'est sisteron
des six bien vu mathieu ah oui les
choses voir français mais ça n'a
peut-être pas non ainsi tu prends ta
d'allemands de cette main parce que j'ai
peur
en fait j'ai ressenti choc grave'
nagasaki soit pas perdre ont tout de
suite ça se fait ou après il sait
défendre a aussi amélioré jbg deux ans
prise à la fin j'étais dans tes
d'apprendre de la dame et après tu
prends g2 mais à la fin il y avait 50
prise mais fou c6 et ça fout pranger
deux français mais ça ça va pas du tout
dans toutes les pierres qui prend des
huit prend à huîtres en bessin raclant
ou 1,8 pour qui est à 7 mai à sète s'est
pas vraiment prises à chaque soirée
plutôt à les prendre à 8
bonjour j'aurais fait comme parce que je
vais choquer décisive tempo c'est pas
faux elle a en tout est fait à tour g1
j'avais pas vu c'est bien joué giresse
aux dominants dans ce début de match
mais c'est un cas qui mène 2 1 en
dominant la troisième essai
et complètement oui mais là il d'ouvrir
bram cannes par rapport aux réalités je
suis d'accord à temps et surtout reprend
1,5 je suis pas sûr mais pas la wii dont
un sac noir schiste avait purgé huit
échecs et ensuite d'avoir un ton tour à
tour 5 1 qui cherche la merde et x 3,5
selon lui fait rage sept jours j 2 de ce
genre de coup tu seras jamais fait mais
ça reste ça c'est pas gagné ça non ces 2
1 milliards soit 7 2 c'était moche
hockey suisse c5 c6 frais aux arcades
bêtes font aller ça gagne si t'arrives
ajoute besson de b3 à b2 tu gagnes ta
faire un petit coup de tours d2 d'en
donner aussi pour moi-même et roi des
six j'aime pas laisser ce roi se
rapprocher la com ça ouais j'aime pas
trop vieux monde
f5 comprends pas ce qui fait pris la
peugeot bécade c5 les sortir est-ce
qu'on clique l'avenir il va il va pas la
gagner il va se faire arnaquer c'est
affreux mathieu ce début de match pour
sow après ce qu'il ya vraiment une
menace non au petit roy avait cette
crise et 6 mai faut prendre ces 4 mai fu
français car je commençais à quelques
tours ces deux mais il faut aussi s'il
ya pas de bonnes découvertes d'atafu p3
aussi dans sa voix il faut que trois
tours c3t sûr tu fais mieux la finale
pas sûr mais je passe sur mais peut-être
ne peut probable de metz à la ntia ouais
tiens c'est facile derrière c'est normal
quoi ce que fait wesley bail
techniquement il se hisse y retourner
mais je trouve qu'ils se retournent et
vêtements genre et position il peut
jouer un contrôle et notre oreille si
c'est celle qui veut jouer miroir 6 7 1
roy non il y avait un cap et ab4 apprend
bay 4-1 mais b43 prendre quatre mais bah
oui il ya là le truc en l'air ok si
votre rêve qu'ils fassent ce qu'elles
aient des quatre mais peut peut-être
même prendre h donnant et surtout
richesse pour le symbole déjà gagné b 6
mai à sa gagne pain bref c'est reparti
la partie allait français qui décide qui
domine tous les coups en franchement
3way 3 et j'ai envie de dire ça fait mal
pour prouesse le vicomte et esport h4 je
suis très inquiet je suis vraiment très
inquiet pour voir s'il est là faut
vraiment qui recolle rapidement au score
qui est qui reviennent tous qui
reviennent dans la zone de -1 et à
égalité je peux pas rester contre maca
dans la zone - 2 - 3 ap rick maintien
dans cette zone là et ces morts là quand
même mal encore ouais là elle part elle
part je sais c'est un bug
ils savent pas comment le régler hk
normalement le fait pas d'un stand de
coûts mais normalement ce n'était pas
censé faire lâche 1 que l'aca transport
nous allume qu'existe j'ai joué au stade
j'ai un parti donc plusieurs fois dit sa
hâte intéressant ouais c'est intéressant
pour une attaque baril est ce que c'est
une fresque allait faire le pas ou tu
fais comme ça vient de chess comme le
bug en fait on n'y peut rien on peut
rien faire pour avoir les calmes en
continu il ya un problème quand c'est de
choper le live sur twitter
donc c'est ya rien à faire à part
essayer de faire des transitions pour
les récupérer c'est pour ça que la
transition pourrait se récupérer les cas
mais en vrai on n'y peut rien bon désolé
mathieu été coupée c'était pour
expliquer d'où venait le pack de pêcher
que ce que j'aurais aussi accablant je
sais pas
moi j'aime toujours bien les noirs dans
cette position là j'ai l'impression que
ce cavalier en c3 est mal placé mais ça
c'est un peu mon tout juste je vais te
dire je te bouffer un pion de logar d'un
bafa la gt retour s'est vite l'homme des
cut
ça peut-être raison mais d'amener case
consolider ses cavaliers 8 il a
consolidé le club des cinq et ramener un
cahier sur f5 et jouer conclusion h4
mais bon même source le blanc sont vieux
jeu de foot est roi bègue at il fait il
fait exactement ce que tu disais mathieu
t1 oracle la cij ou beckett c'est de la
folie
bailly va jouer mais quatre ans cuisse
non mais non ils vous arrivent à jeu le
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'il faut contrôler
et e5 et des 5
non je pense qu'il faut donner ce qu'il
faut trouver un moyen de après les noirs
menace peut-être juste d'un bassin qui
essaie donc d4 fait ça fait vraiment
sens oui et b4 des foyers payeront
d'hésiter ok ça c'est typique n'a qu'à
ce genre de coup je pense jamais racing
risque sur puis on prend est offerte et
34 et devenir s'introduire sur axis
ouais alors même son cavalier 5
ainsi si ce faux problème ça ok non mais
je prendrai jamais henri iv il a fait
repousser si c'est logique
maintenant os les e-menaces soit
peut-être que l'on prend ils menacent
wayne patrouillent et menacent à jay dix
pays voilà c'est une menace à damas cinq
phrases en refaisant faisant question de
faire un petit bilan en gros tard
qu'opposer talent cavalli ranger ça et
on sait pas ok la case f5 avait pas
d'ego
là ils jouent pour rejoindre mais là je
me demandais de 5 pour les blancs quand
tu vends f5 je te prends c'est pas bête
et tu veux g4 est ouvert le roi pour le
blanc après les noirs doivent essayer
des bêtises défaut d'un bassin il faut
bouger une bouffée heureux au moins
regagner un pion ce qui est dommage pour
moi et c'est ce qui la fout de cases
blanches et à tous les gars sur blanc
savait qui perdure a attaqué je préfére
et 11,5 à f4
mais après ouais mais son idée c'est
peut-être qu'ils menacent d'en c'est
peut-être la même chose ok admettons et
je n'ai pas le temps de prendre quatre
ici pour tel site soulager d'un raid je
crois juste que tactique non je prends
et je prends du fou de cela mais je veux
jouer wesley aller aux idées que mais
j'ai peut-être pas miro j'ai changé une
tour je ferais g37 3g change pas tout de
suite j'attends que tu me le force parce
que sinon ils tuent vais me prendre pour
des quatre noms mais je comprends que
c'est dur mais est-ce que cinq ici non
ça marchera pas bien j'en prends
cavaliers e6 d'un bouche des gets
peut-être pas idiot à temps il a joué
mathieu il a joué tama cinq voisins tous
que il aurait dû genre je convaincs trop
lisse genre si tu es juste eu 5 kg 4
vraiment en fait le gros avantage à 21
g7 c'est quand tu me fais j'éclate je
suis pas mal tout de suite tu es je peux
attendre
tu peux voir venir et l5 aussi qui peut
être candidat mais elle 5e 5 des quatre
peut-être y arrive vite mais peut-être
que puis on prend 1,4 va commencer à
être un jour une idée pour eux enfin
donc il va bouffer ça donc il n'y a pas
d'âme à da costa et f6 il n'ya pas y'a
pas peut-être qui doit tout cas ceux
d'idc
alors il peut pas juste prendre et
prendre là j'aurais jamais fait ça avec
killing the dome b3 mais j'aurais jamais
fait ça avec les blancs cavaliers way
turow c'est chaud attend à voir voir ce
qui s'est passé c'est chaud c'est chez
les amis fous prend prises le français
5e dames et trois c'est la partie
mathieu est connue le 6 mai désolé
désolé les mecs on vous pas eu de toutes
les parties on voit tous les coups je
suis je suis vraiment je m'excuse auprès
on a pas vu mais c'est le jeu tourne b6
non mais je m'excuse je m'excuse
vraiment auprès du public m'a que c'est
pas marrant d'avoir des commentateurs
d'un tel niveau mathieu en appelant dit
qu on a pas leur dit non on n'a pas le
redis on fait sans ordi en a marre
quatre tombes et six fours f7 trois sets
je pense si tu pars vers h6 au pire ça
donne quoi ça ça donne pas envie mais
attends ça joue sajou il a fait damas
trois directs et change et karelia 5000
noms sont sortis mais les noirs sont
peut-être même symboliquement mieux non
trois ans atteinte un peu non mais oui
ça va ça ça ferait du bien au moral de
wesley de s'en sortir après les
poubelles oui ouais ça ça relancerait
dans le match propos de nul de naka
hockey accepté par wesley est bon c'est
bien ça revient c'est bien quand le noir
de sauver une peuvent maintenant c'est
important ouais ça permet de
des salaires il voulait me donner des
pièces wire tu étais pas tu étais pas
hyper performant jeter moins enfants
payer le loyer des trucs marrants jardin
ces structures plainte si tu joues ta
mère trois banques et que j'ai déjà joué
d'ailleurs les noirs tu me l'as tu veux
na sky dessin mais sur un schisme le
redis il dit que francis d'un enfant
n'est pas forcément mieux ce drôle ça
j'ai déjà regardé sam hallucine
et là je demeure 3way les qualités 4c
mormon dernière phrase c'est ma partie
contre contre l'ami et là tu fais bc oui
voilà c'est ça la avec bc je me disais
bien qu'il avait investi quelque part
les travaux le psg joue sans proches et
ce nul contre la slovénie
l'année dernière mais je me rappelle et
j'étais mieux mais après j'avais raté un
coup précis et après j'avais limite eu
besoin de deux là avaient souffert non
mais était ce genre de truc qui
constellent mieux et en fait c'est dur
de changer ton mindset son état d'esprit
va les chercher là nul quand il avait
déchiré dans l'ouverture très dur ça
vous est cher h3 infligé 4 était une
idée oui mais ça j'adore pour les
blanches absent que le roi il est
tellement dur à attaquer mais le truc
station de thé finale n'était pas
forcément mieux je vais je dois me 5 ait
eu à forcer faut prendre et si c'est
tout est changé c'est ça l'accueil
l'adorent ces petites finales puisque
fouet
khaddam adams et 5 km peu avant mais je
crois qu'il doit jouer la finale non je
ne rêve pas avoir d'autres coups mois
après peut-être que tint bon
non il va rentrer dedans façon que tu
comprends je pense tu peux pas y
accorder 5 côté noir dingue dingue c'est
logique veut jeu des finales mais je
comprends bien mais je mets ça c'est
vraiment complètement égal non je vois
pas dans quel
monde balita des pions faible j'avais
des deux côtés tu fais c'est si je
repars état des six sièges
ça me créer une target que oui mais je
vais retourner une fois et si si si je
crois il veut jouer peut-être pour
detroit je sais pas laquelle il voulait
m c'était pas perdre pour vous pouvez
faire tout rejettant ouais mais y aura
toujours un g7 ou non je veux jouer le
taureau noteront que tu vas jouer pour
tour à tour j'ai trois tours f3 ou aussi
ses échecs a toujours droit et fuite
vers ce genre ific ça c'est sûr ça je
voulais jetons 1 3 vous prendrez cinq
pions prends et je la finale de pions
d'un tueur fou et si tu fais toujours là
je prends 5
ok si tu prends il veut prendre 2e c'est
ça et tu te dire que sa structure c'est
moins grave que la tête
c'est ça que je voulais faire ouais gens
te met une tournage de tron tour
menaçait de mettre une droite trop de
force tout en bloc et met alors à qui on
avait fuité la codah cola ne tue rendent
jamais un torse est hyper bizarre allez
le tour tiger bizarre juste je me lasse
pas vraiment hors 8 il y aura un
processus qui fera peut-être fou 17
est-ce que je peux pas joe c4 maintenant
tu commences à chercher les zones merde
non je fais retour j'aurai fait tout 1 3
mais depuis moi je l'aurais fait le plus
longtemps vous voilà je pense qu'il a dû
jouer ça pour gagner un peu de temps
j'en avais tours 1-3 non mais là faut
pas faire non mais c'est n'importe quoi
non mais je pense qu'il y avait plus
d'avantagés en nature
oui et non il a peut-être raison mais
il ya toujours deux points d'écart et
n'a qu'à qui construit son match et s'il
y est mais qui est dégoûté la loupiote
attention je vais je vais essayer de
remettre les calmes
si on y arrive aux mille et redit
françois baldé chasse comme à 1000 euros
différentes la bonne nuit enfin si voir
les rediffusions de la chaîne chaise
comme je passe chez ascom france ils ont
fait aussi mais tu es obligé d'être seul
maintenant est de payer mais c'est ce
que je vous disais un de toute façon ça
va venir de partout cette histoire de
sabaly c'est une diffusion sur twitch
match que tu t'es pas renier détail est
d'accord ou t'es pas d'accord à monsieur
je peux développer si tu veux discuter
de ça deux minutes ça t'intéresse je
peux développer un petit peu m'expliquer
comment on parle
ouais voilà alors soit on parle en fait
si on te soutenir une chaîne
financièrement tu peux sabaa chaîne mais
je sais même pas combien ça coûte
comment ça coûte 5 euros par mois
en gros ça c'est les gars contre qui tu
joues quand on fait des soirées sound
ces caméras de la chaîne d'accord le
délire avant sur twitter était de donner
des petits avantages au sol pour faire
un peu des soirées comme on faisait nous
avec toi par exemple celle que tout le
monde peut le voir donc tout le monde en
profite et avait un petit plus pour les
gens qui étaient la chaîne c'était
normal est maintenant faite et un
nouveau délire qui est en train
d'arriver de plus en plus sur twitch
c'est c'est de passer en fait toutes les
rediffusions en fait de plus pouvoir
voir les rues de pouvoir voir le live
pour tout le monde et tout ce qui est
redit fusion de faire ce bolide être
obligé de payer pour le faire et le
problème de cette histoire-là du sabbat
ni sur moi je veux pas le faire sur ma
chaîne perso mais le problème c'est que
si toutes les chaînes le font les gens
en fait ils vont seuls aux chaînes qui
bloque le contenu pour les gens qui sont
pas seuls sur ce que je veux dire et
donc c'est un peu le système que sita
15% des chaînes qui le font mad à 100%
qu'ils vont le faire parce que sinon les
gens ils vont aller sauf chez les autres
savons pas chez toi parce que toi tu
fais que du gratuit tu vois et donc ça
va forcer à tout le monde à le faire
en réalité donc c'est un peu dommage en
soi mais c'est comme ça les gens ils
peuvent le voir en live cgc la rue il ya
beaucoup de gens qui veulent voir leurs
clés russie thiès comme il m'est rien
sur youtube après ça il m eur de moins
en moins de choses mais c'est juste
parce que c'est les concurrences
non non non non c'est juste que en
réalité mettre tout le contenu
twitch sur youtube c'est pas vraiment
une bonne idée parce que ceux des
contenus qui sont différents et donc
donc c'est pour ça mais eux ils mettent
beaucoup de choses sur les deux plates
formes est ok moreau venant à bout sont
les noirs ont très bien géré et
l'ouverture
je pensais après plus j'y pense moi
aussi écrire tout au long des six peut
être faible je mette un frein aux un
grief qu'a tu vas y c'est juste faire
des 500 débarrasser allait faire mieux
je prend 1,4 oui là maintenant tu peux
pas rue
mais concrètement tu vas pas y arriver
j'aime bien à 6e mathieu bessin quoi
lancer l'idée qui est fiat g6 fou ce 3
de 5
un truc comme ça tu vas faire des cinq
toutes les sélections et joël active à
fond bon il n'a pas fait pas trop son
genre ouais il politique et la région
match peu comment tu l'appelles si le
mec mais mal ces pièces l'espace quoi je
pense que l'ordinateur du coup il
comprend pas tout à bien poser des
pièces sur l'échiquier mais c'est moi je
pense que c'est une super innovation
perso j'en sais que ça existait déjà en
fait ça existait mais il paraît que
c'était pas c'était pas top top là ces
nouvelles versions inquiète c'est bien
ce qui me semblait avoir déjà vu je sais
plus comment ça s'appelait d'ailleurs
mais là ça a l'air vraiment bien ce
régime d'air c'est peut-être la même
société qui le fait je prendrai en des
cinq mâts et a du mal à être mieux parce
que si tu vends m6 le football est ainsi
4 mettez pas moi mais remet ce qu'on
peut être mieux avec les noirs il va
allumer la lumière bientôt les gazons
jack et dépend donc pour les scores ils
sont écrits à côté du nom des joueurs
est désolé il ya c'est vraiment un
problème technique qui nous empêche
d'avoir pourquoi sa pole dès qu'on dit
d'eux d'avoir les caméras et on a du mal
à y faire quelque chose dont je vais
essayer de faire un jeu abstrait mais
jouent au chat c'est le s'éviterait
j'ai des mandats des maillons l'été
j'avais déjà joué avec oui tu avais joué
un match de pro che slick je pense à
l'acte no way
roquet est ce qu'il est pas mieux petit
à petit wesley me sens mieux depuis le
début mais est-ce qu'on peut pas je sais
quatre intrus dans sage conseil à wc3
cette robe feu le 3e set mais j'ai
l'impression et être quatre tours 8
c'est la variante c'est la partie
mathieu 8
c'est important les gars de bien
comprendre qu'avec une seule colonne
ouverte le joueur qui la contrôlent avec
l'adour
il a joué ses deux mais je pense qu'il
faut prendre on apprend et ils veulent
pas précis il manque de précision de
quelques moments importants si le match
si le score s'était délitée rien à dire
oui je pense d'ailleurs que c'est le
score logique je vais faire apparaître
les calmes en testant un nouveau truc ça
va pas durer c'est ça je pense pas mais
mais on attend pour le mans ils sont là
j'aurais pas mal tu dois aller voir sur
le partage d'écran là mathieu ne voit
que la moitié du tube je vous laisse je
vais la partie droite et merci et merci
à gals fille pour pour le tweet prime
merci tonton tu fait plaise région le
prix ce qui disait tout à l'heure c'est
qu'on le saura dans d'autres jours il a
joué oui oui ça joue ça ça je vous salue
la paperie là et nul à châteauroux 8
mais non c'est bien dommage 5 tours 8
doit être en les tongiens on prend un
tour gérard et toi c'est quoi ça va
faire un tour à schwyz ils essayent de
cloud et ils peuvent faire tout re à
huit tours à six tours à schwyz
ah ça sent que tout chargé il veut quoi
il veut sur deux comment ça marche dans
ces quatre échecs tour eu deux royaumes
oui c'est la partie le 6 tours juin on
l'a vu il peut prendre effet retour en
échec quand tu fais ton genre ça va être
la partie bref sinon méprisé f5 potter
en fait pourquoi il a fait tord eu des
échecs c'est très con il pouvait jouer
en transit 6 oui l'opium projet sirh f 5
tessi manque de précision dans les monts
assez simple un homme mais kiev 5 g en
train d'y penser n'y a pas de tour h cet
atout rage sept tours h4 sûr à tout un
tour de matt
ouais donc du cou de taureau qu'à trois
tours h est obligé de 3,8
torje un droite g8 tongiens c'est le
seul coup en lançant le projet wave
systems est ouverte cette 21è attend ici
je fais tout rêve deux tours h un tour
eu deux tours à je suis 3g c'est de ces
nuls quoi quoique courage cette
chaufferie roi ça invite web de tomber
cette norme il avait raison ça défend
db2 ah oui c'est fondé mais dont il veut
tout rêve de tour de maintenant mais la
différence c'est que maintenant son tour
h 1 il doit il doit bouger la torche un
visa touriste probablement tour trois
tours 3 autour de 80 parce que s'il
faisait huit ans prise
on est bien d'accord il pouvait pas
regarder la tour huit ans plus tard
temps qu'est ce qui peut faire
maintenant
honteux rêve de maintenant est vraiment
un coup franc moi je vais faire tourache
2 1 pour empêcher il passe pour age 2 g
je pense de cette sombre d'eux mêmes et
non
ouais l'idée c'est ça ces jeunes ont
beaucoup en fait il va te faire e stop
mais je pense qu'il va gagner avec les
bleus ça c'est une très mauvaise
nouvelle pour nous d'ailleurs
ouais je pense que c'est mort l'image
regrette g7 il va faire un hub et tous
rêvent qu'à tuera tous rachats oui il ya
tout rachat ouais détourage suite maths
c'est parti ouais ouais c'est ce que
j'avais vu je veux y a pas deux nuls
donc 5e aux mines paris domine à ok
cette fois c'était nul c'était plutôt le
résultat logique il se fait retourner
nommé rock mais regardez nana canada qui
fait des grimaces et la regarde pas si
c'est fini c'est affreux c'est une
horreur mathieu c'est reparti pour une
ak je pense qu'il faut vraiment pas
mettre sa canne baril alors surtout
surtout faut pas faire des débuts de
match de merde comme faisceau excuse moi
mais non mais regarde ça y est non mais
ça c'est insupportable
donc c'est la même partie que tout à
l'heure un nous on aimait bien les
blancs dans cette partie je sais pas le
commandant comment on va faire quand on
va jouer contre eux en pro-chasse ligue
1 franchement c'est un portable c'est
pas obligés de mettre leurs canons
oui mais on va savoir qui fait ça ouais
bah si tu le regardes pas ça va j'espère
qu'ils vont sortir un baume à un gros
match aller petit aussi surtout que je
vais jouer si tu penses que tu vas jouer
franchement j'en sais rien je crois que
t'as pas donner l'équipe en quoi non
mais je la connais est ce que tu penses
que je vais être surpris non je pense
pas tu maîtrises quelle équipe toi il y
en a que deux possibles non il y en a 3
possible à mon avis
norma et v3 comprend possible madonna
donnent la compo favorites on saura paca
est la deuxième dans la compacte aurait
misé un millier de musées el baki maxime
la garder au 4ème juste entre götze et
romain après la mort aussi mais boher il
stresse un peu moi j'ai pas très bien
joué libye aussi on amélie vivace en ont
le garde pour l'arménie on va pas écrasé
la compétition dès ce jour là du coup
ils sont en train de répéter des et non
c'est pas logique parce que j ai moi je
citais différemment mais bon dieu peut
dire non les villages où le job moi j'ai
hésité entre romain et maxime la gamme
ouais ouais mais il est la plus plus
longtemps et il a juste du mas motivé
mais candice motive l'autre jour il
avait un jeu par vincent la décision la
décision plus ou moins prise voiture qui
nous dira oui et non en fait j'attends
juste avoir la confirmation que tout le
monde puisse vraiment pour le jour jouer
mais je préfère toujours les blondes
mais bon ça reste solide et nous voici
qui fait une sale tête d'un petit
migraine ouais non faut qu'il fasse une
prière à la pause
[Musique]
cette blague voiture complètement assumé
les religions oui oui c'est son droit le
plus fondamental le lieu d'avoir une
petite fille anne mais pas prendre
et s'ils feront aussi safran je vais
faire et france 5 peut-être cia mais
alors dans l'anti positionnelle taef 4
qui est pas mal ici les secours doit que
je tour f1 oui ici tu veux te faire f 4
filets le pion être époux fait ça et
c'est non mais ça je veux pas le faire
mais peu
qu'il faut faire un truc comme ça après
on peut aussi je tombe à fanta il a fait
il l'a fait vrai m'a dit on a rêvé ou
est ce les saules a fait mais ce que
c'est pas très bon signe pour lui pour
tous écoutent bahreïn ont fait ce qu'ils
peuvent
c'est encore repartir partie des cas
mais je fais ce que je fais honnêtement
je fais vraiment ce que je peux non moi
je te prouve
oui mais jeudi pour toi je sais que tu
me crois mais une petite pause entre les
deux sessions comment ça marche
il ya cinq minutes de pause way ou 6 me
de pause entre et entre les deux
sessions à vue mais pas beaucoup mangé
tu vas manger de manière réduite
je n'en doute pas uniforme haletant un
bon français le buzz tu as des tic
hanley non quels sont les hyperviseurs
je passe g3 pas le bon mais j'ai 3g 6
ben tu repars comme ça est ce un week
end tu vends que j'ai deux soit protégé
le pion et puis non mais je crois que
nice et saint jean de boa constrictor
dans ce match est en réalité ouest et y
réussit pas aux terres dans une position
d qui joue pour le cas il se fait
contrer c'est vraiment le mauvais
scénario malheureuse et quand il a des
bonnes chaussures il est gagné d perrin
j'ai du fromage états unis et du vrai
fromage
gigi ou de l'autruche ah c'est bon ça
passe est bon si c'est bon non c'est bon
mais ouais du coup il a pas eu envie de
choquer h4 à cause de jets 5 rouleaux et
du coup tu peux même être moins bien ça
c'est final un peu à la scandinave va
pas essayer de faire tour ici touristes
sur wave 2 est plein d'étapes a le temps
on y verse un quadra le tour 8
faut faire gaffe à f/5 majoré par
contout vent vient je peux pousser le 5
oui tu attends 17 et chats car mes oeufs
sains ce qui va nous faire 1,3 g 8 g 4
ok ça c'est bien je n'en sais rien mais
c'est qu'un
du coup ça a tellement être là reste
chez moi ce soir avec un scène un bus et
nîmes que j'ai déjà joué à cannes en mai
mais il ay l'ain
il a une très mauvaise gestion du temps
saab mais derrière je vous ai écoutés
vite fait et tu lui as dit là je lui ai
dit un moment tu as dit mais tu as joué
beaucoup trop vite là non il a dit oui
c'est vrai et c'est vrai et peugeot 2 6
1 6 3 et 6 ces chiens non mais c'est pas
évident parce que j'ai fait j'ai mon
point de vue sur ce qui fait ou pas mais
il est quand même plus fort que moi donc
c'est difficile de nom mais sa gestion
du temps l'autre jour étaient très
mauvaises de ce fait un
il doit réfléchir à vendre ou à acheter
oui bien sûr parce que c'est un coup
tellement responsable tu peux pas ok
après je sais qu'il ya plein de joueurs
qui font ça et des biens meilleurs que
moi mais moi je ne peux pas juin cosson
réfléchir même si hockey il avait uni
qui gagne je dois moi je vérifie non
honnêtement quand on a suivi avec femmes
ce qui nous a le plus surpris dans la
partie c'était la vitesse à laquelle ça
va jouer damas et deux dans la balle
dans la partie contrat route parce que
des cas nous paraissait tellement
principal de philippe yon linge est pas
rien et c'est un excellent il prend ses
décisions assez vite mais après je sais
que m
mais il a joué h 3 en 20 secondes donc
et il a réfléchi trois minutes pour
jouer deux fois avant et tu dois
vérifier dans ta vie oui oui
non mais après ça dépend aussi du style
je pense pas que ce soit son par la
tactique c'est pas forcément son gros
point fort et qui épreuve de tu dois
vérifier
surtout contre un mec est hyper tactique
ouais c'est dommage y'a pas si on prend
des six maintenant avec la tour en
recettes
si c'est pas une gaffe juste parce que
ouais 3-2 puis on prend 1,7 et f5 qu'ils
renault quittent première gaffe de naka
franchement l'annoncé de la première
mais c'est la première qui peut coûter 1
il peut la tenue un prise est tombé 5
après et chatin kanak annonce match
exclusion de cabu l'air parce que ça
fait quelques fois que en fait si les
airs a confié toute la partie c'est pas
volé en fait tord au synchrotron il va
te faire à 4 il va pas la gagner on
restait possible que si jean roy 4-1
j'aurai fait tout re crois que je pense
que c'est pas bête non mais c'était mon
idée première
tu veux jouer le roi j'ai 4 h 5 j'ai
peut-être que je à 4 et 3 3 au tour ces
deux notes aura trois fois deux têtes
comme hier je me trompe de cases ça
commence par ailleurs c'est bien oui
c'était le festival de l'attendu
trompage de 15 ans et ça c'est à ce
point
ouais ouais tu sais tu es el festival od
de la case oui j'arrive à nu et dont je
suis pas sûr que les désirs cisjordanie
de tomber trois tours c'est de temps
mettra que j'y crois pas à perso après
tout ce que je voulais faire un truc
comme ça mais je vois pas comment ça
peut marcher
je crois qu'ils arrière mathieu
donc ouais ouais c'est mais bon à
kananga la réussite en franchement elin
mann - ils abattent les c5
je comprends pas il veut jouer à
killzone 2 us oui mais tous les pions de
notre côté mais hyper désorganisé pour
la le jeu h4h 1 mais je veux et ce qui
peut pas jouer à 5 man n'a qu'à pas se
refroidir
c'est légal
c'est même un bon coup probablement mais
maintenant h4 peut-être c'est simple ces
symboles comme quand on sait qu'un
traitement ni des premières mais à
chaque fois et enfin 5 5 se rode que ça
va faire nul 5-5 sahraouis à 5
mais bon peu importe trois des quatre
cents et 3 et 4 c 5
il rend pas je veux aussi faire échec et
revenir à nantes au prince sont gênés
3-3 et c'est sacré ah non ça va pas la
mâture le retour du calme à pine island
ah oui je prends une leçon de réalisme
maximal il va fort être chaud an pour
pour le 4 mars 1 on sait qu'il est chaud
maxime oui oui mais pour l'instant il
fait le taff 1 il est interdit union
peut pas lui reprocher c'est que je suis
là voulu gagner donc on reprocha on
reproche jamais à quelqu'un de
rochus on lui reproche rien à une trompe
aux familles s'inspire de moi à
l'accueil en a marre tout pareil on
entend que la petite plein derrière de
temps en temps ça rajoute un peu de
charme au stream
désolé ça elle grandit bien ouais enfin
les petites crevettes
elle ressemble à un moment déjà elle a
les cheveux je fais petite scène on a
énormément beaucoup trop et papa non pas
du tout un peu donc bref j'y joue ce un
bien il met les autres connector il me
le faut près même si maxi essaiera de se
mettre au niveau de fabi biret mais bon
c'est quand même c'est quand même un peu
présomptueux ta part maxime on sait que
tu as du talent mais bon se mettre au
niveau de libye quand même ça me paraît
un peu difficile quoi ça me paraît un
peu difficile mais ça et que libye là
dans le dans le petit teaser pour la
prod châssis gaver fantastique mais ça
vient du film oui je sais je sais moi je
préfère les noix je déteste fou j'ai 5
et 6 3 j'arrive vraiment jamais à
comprendre les jurés dans les trucs à d4
d5 je n'arrive pas à comprendre comment
un cavalier peut être bien en c3 ajouté
que ça je sais que c'est possible mais
je n'arrive pas à avoir imaginé que ce
soit quelque chose de sain et bon tu as
un petit moment et qui participe au
centre mathieu n'en voyez moi j'aime pas
trop hein après on s'en fout voyez où
selon félicien là on est mieux on ne
fait plus rien que je suis mieux je ne
joue plus mais f4 il va un moment de
faire jeu égal mais ce que je peux
m'énerver affaire j'ai 5 flashlite grand
roque et faire juger que je m'énerve
hall lentilles du f4 light attaques des
cats 6 buts
après il peut y avoir un chat en le
bourrant je fais j'ai 5 fu et 2
franchement je fais j'ai cinq là
honnêtement franchement on voit l'ac
fini de rigoler je t'envoie le pion tu
fais pas non mais c'est en fait un
tonneau nous mettons des huit jurés
jamais fait et puisque tu te gares des
banques
bah oui mais c'est évident enfin là
c'est manger ça et franchement c'était
un beau coup il veut jeu peut-être
cavaillé leucate et qu'un jour la tour
soit utile sur la colonne des eaux très
proches l'un des liens qu'elle a tord
sur youtube il reste combien de temps as
on en a on n'a pas les chronos on a rien
à temps on essaie de l'arrogance
non je voulais voir de temps dans le
dans la cadence mais je ne sais pas ce
qu'il a fait avec leur rock
je trouve qu'il va jouer du côté où les
planches où la semaine et pendant plus
on sauve se méfier de nature on dirait
tôt vendre beaucoup le jeu masqué sais
pas ce qu'il en pense maxime de l'idée
du avec gt5 c'est lui ça lui paraissait
complètement fou la bosse était notre
première idée mais oui mais peut-être
que maxime il va dire non c'est très
mauvais peut-être ce coup n'appartenait
pas à cette position mais blatt ventes à
6 qu'après le speech à junior le match
magma glouglou contre contre xiang
en fait ils pensent que s'ils se remet
qu'il est en forme il le remet plus un
coût plus 6 en mars au mieux je pense
pas qu'il soit très bon pas sa relative
faille est plus fort que moi et votre
main mais je ne trie les patrons il sera
jamais monstreux mais ça c'est sûr pas
c'est fini ce type n'est pas à la fête
il est un rush et tout mais le héros
flotte il a perdu leur nombre de froid
je fais déchirer avec deux noirs oui
mais bon après de la sq ben laden serait
entraînant lui mettre plus 5600 l'om qui
croient pas non
après ça a été à l'époque je pense que
le grand
anglade de la grande époque il aurait pu
il aurait pu y mettre un gros score ça
c'est vrai attention à la de 2007 2008
vous les 5 et 6 pour jouer aux trois
ouais mais fou ou trois je pense que les
plans sont musiciens
après je fais tout reste quatre tours f1
je vais peut-être avoir des tours fc
saint geours j'étais naïve sonde m6 tout
est changé d'âme si c'était très naïf
mais je pense que petit rock était
vraiment ma terrible hein ça par contre
c'est bien joué
il n'est même pas ton g5 web en mai ces
grottes qui n'appartient pas sa puce ou
wayne rock tuer le fait que quand tu
n'as pas de choses bon je fais confiance
câble a atteint 60 ans que vlad n'a pas
dit ça peut encore être en bons coups 1
tu sais que j'ai un soutien envoyés ou
pas il gît un troll super sur la ddt
non mais un peu ça c'est pas vraiment un
troll d'ailleurs j'ai un exo super à
montreuil se fera hors ligne il me dira
peut-être coprah et vidéo dessus sont ko
la lave et comment ça parle d'argent sur
ce stream incroyable ça le joueur
français eux j'étais raconter ça m'a
fait super plaisir j'ai un projet un
élève qui m'envoyait un une pause il me
dit t'as vu ce qu'il a raté en parlant
d'une partie et c'est un élève qui avait
regardé le dvd et saint louis basket
vous prendrez 5 avril vont comment je te
comprend des 5 kg 4 j'ai vu cet exemple
je suis choqué comment ne pas faire faf
également il aurait fallu aussi voir la
méthode
j'ai donné cet exo deux fois à des
personnes qui ont acheté le dvd
ils ont fait quelques aurait vu qu'en
penseront qu'ils avaient pas garder le
chapitre wayana ya ma pub 2 qui ont pas
regarder chapitre il y en a un qui avait
oublié par ça c'est le pire après deux
montées
by tout ça ils ont trouvé tempo vrai fan
m'a envoyé le pgl à la pollution dont tu
parles en fait je oui mais il m'a
renvoyé mais il fait comment ne pas
trouver j'ai vu où ils vont prendre les
5 tout le monde c'est bon et ça va pour
la norme en fait c'est le meilleur club
et ce qui est marrant c'est que lila le
trouve tempo donc ça on s'en doutait bon
ben là de le trouve foetus ouais mais
non il le trouva prézidan donc c'est
violer elle n'était pas si jeune mais
par contre le truc qui est génial c'est
que stockfisch 11 sûrement ma grosse
bécane le trouve tempo ce que stockfisch
sur mon ordi portable trouve quoi c'est
drôle à dire qu'ils ont placées même de
programs
donc pour ceux qui savent pas trop où on
parle on parle de dé changer le dans le
pion isolé d'échangés le fou de cases
blanches contre un cavalier pour jouer
sur les cases noires quand même en ont
fait justice il n'y a pas fou prend 1 à
froid 6 et dante petit moule faut croire
6 vous prendrez 4 mai fu et trois non
mais il ya demain ce matin pascal mais
également à ses échecs
c'est la partie ça non il a fait tout
prend ses 8 mai je vérifie alors dit sa
grille franchie ce non match et ce avec
quoi demain est fait d'un prince is d'un
projet sismo faut prendre les cargos
doivent donc ouais mais tous rêvent de
il te prends à f2
il situe français purple temps qu'il
fait 3 ou sous des capes bon peu importe
c'était joli hein mais il faut prendre
tour c'est vrai que ça gagne comme ça
c'est une qualité pendant les fouilles
points à six semaines en marche que tu
as ton idée oui parce que si on prend
des cartes il faut croire oui c'est fini
ça va faire 4 points d'écart pour le
pour le joueur bon bah ouais ça va être
pas très intéressant mais il se prend
toutes les peaux de banane ouais il
démis pense qu'il n'a pas bien manger il
avait l'air fatigué le petit hall à
cannes
je pense au niveau des poulets qui n'a
pas été à eric thébault les haricots
verts à face à leurs formes et les
ruelles et ma tondeuse
alors après tant qu au retour c1 dames
f1 comme si on attendra pour certains
prendre
heureusement d'ailleurs que tu as faux
bond même et ses déchets alors qu'on
espère avoir quand même du plus de
suspens
moi qui reste combien de temps tu peux
rien c'est un faux enfin en fait j'ai du
mal à voir toutes les infos là je suis
en difficulté d'un faux j'essaie de
récupérer les calmes autant que possible
les mecs je donne tout pour avoir les
quarts en réalité mais j'arrive pas à
les récupérer c'est une horreur je suis
dégoûté en vrai pourquoi y être son
époux daniela ne se fait que d'apprendre
que je veux qui est rugby mais j'arrive
pas à récupérer les calmes je suis
vraiment à ça et on les a de nouveau eu
lieu dans me1 il reste 20 me dans la
cadence
mais je suis dégoûté du scénario quand
même bah ouais surtout que le début de
match sow domine après west ingénieux
s'il te plaît nous avait énervé avec
cette prod cette ligue mais à la base de
mathieu si c'est pour faire des coups je
suis un peu dégoûté
franchement c'est pour faire des jeux de
mots comme ça mathieu passe passe alors
ce que j'ai fait à temps le jeu de mots
que tu viens de faire
j'ai pas fait ouais on la fait pas à moi
je pense que tout le monde l'a compris
dans le chat les mecs
tout le monde a vu le jeu de mots de
mathieu genre en scred tu tu maintiens
que l'a pas fait exprès non saisie je
vous fais tu sois tu sais au moins ce
que tam a fait exprès voilà voilà voilà
où on en est sur ce stream voilà on a on
a des gens qui prennent la confiance qui
commence à nous tirer vers le bas les
gars elle était belle maturité black and
i'm here ses positions c'est toujours un
truc de fou j'ai toujours eu
l'impression que les blancs étaient
mieux mais en fait c'est à peut être
hyper dangereux pour les blancs ça tu
penches maître croc est-ce que ça
partira de position ouais c'est beau
quand le gars qui n'a qu'une idée quoi
grand roque donc gros qui va arriver il
va envoyer nakai sur le roi mais sow il
peut prendre un il peut il peut prendre
un gros score ce soir à mon amiens et là
ça serait bien qu'ils la giz blues là
c'est leur c4 b6 et ils nous l'ont
michael numéro un mondial en cinq plus
un saut 1
mais ces débours gens nous ont
clairement 17 comprends je comprend rien
à ces pauses en fait c'est simple mais
il va faire fouet cette cave est le 6e
tour débute au maroc ils font ils font
un maximum qu'un jour
mais ça valait faut aussi savoir et au
simple de faire car il ya le 5
ça marche ça marche at je me prononce
pas 3 mars j'ai pas à temps je leur dis
ouais ça marche je me tourne faut
prendre c'est la partie c'était un peu
mieux comme un bon mais il faut que
ceux-là gagne ça la même c'est pas gagné
pas encore
toro un fou prend 2,3 milliards et un
peu honnêtement il a vraiment pas de
chance après la ruine après c'est sûr il
a la tête dedans non mais comme tout à
l'heure il gagne un pion la finale
figure la fois les gagnants il a perm
[Musique]
on comprend qu'ils aient les blancs sont
un peu mieux quand même qu'edf cinq fois
et skaff faut se dépêcher grand roque et
encore les gars ou pas ah oui c'est
encore légal petit face à kiev 5 g 6ème
ghréline ou la gagne cette finale avec
les deux couleurs dans la même fenêtre
kf5 et tu peux pas jouer pour eux sfef
cateau 5g pas si vous avez vu des
sonates ta vu d'assez natu pa veritas
note
en fait j'ai une théorie sur death note
si tu l'as tu l'as vu c'est qu'en fait
keira steve la dent fait les prénoms de
zebra guy robin c'est le méchant qui
manipule tout le monde pour tuer tout le
monde est en fait ben moi j'ai une
nouvelle version enfin je vois pas
comment ce gars super doué aurait pu se
faire attraper
enfin ça ne peut être que vlad quoi
c'est elle notre sein
et après il est remplacé par haine donc
un certain david navarra qu'on a reconnu
je vois pas dans quel monde dhabi
navarra
on peut faire quoi que ce soit mais pour
elle a fait grand roque pourquoi tu
laisses ton rang 8 à l'essai dac avec
les noirs heureusement je suis pour les
blancs un full
le 5 ans va éviter d'aller je comprends
pas pourquoi tu fais pas croire il n'a
pas eu sa copine seulement je donnerai
pas de qui on sait pas de qui palm fait
je pense que death note c'est super mais
faut quand même cinq prises fawcett ça
gagne pas encore je point tu en prends
comprends tu peux pas prendre refuge et
5,6 ou protectorats 7 mai mais il est
évidemment on a cassé s'échappe lourd
dans les sacs royal t'as rien vu t'as
pas fait grand roque et ça tient
quelle horreur mais rennes intérim ok il
a bien jeu de garder les tours mais il
avait tord 17 au prochain monde n'a qu'à
quelle erreur de vlad
ah oui oui mais oui vlad a fait trop
dormi en allemand je serais pas surpris
que vlad sûr tu veux dire manivelle faut
qu'il nous faudra qu'ils nous lâchent
des infos pendant les candidats qui est
requis il doit y avoir des trucs qui
sait déjà que nous on sait pas on sait
on sait qu adams aide caruana c'est tous
des choses après ouais mais moi j'en
sais pas beaucoup hein je la gagne cela
t'inquiète bien honnêtement je pense
qu'il la gagne tu la gagnes mais on sait
déjà que la gagne quand apple en puces
mais je sais que c'est tout
il menaçait dessin tu perds tu pars tu
parles d'une partie contre un certain
dimitri j - emilie ces finales j'adore
est ce que tu peux pas essayer d'avoir
un plan afin de reprendre des quatre
temps prend des cinq héros un des quatre
à quatre baies 5 1 gueugnon passionnés
de côté par quand ici free sujet simple
encore bon a prêté des fois c'est le
genre de ces des fois ça peut être
contre productif ce genre de truc ce que
ça te crées une faiblesse en hachis ce
qui est plus facilement atteints comme
j'étais en retard sur le stream
d'accord c'est penser par avance ce qui
se passe sur ce triste
il répondait que et la gagne mais
j'avais dit cette phrase ya 10 minutes
[Rires]
j'ai un maxi dip ou rechute compte uc la
vie mais peut-être qu'il a
or for cats et pas l'idée là en fait
j'ai peut-être un petit lag sur le hall
6 x 4 courage cinq ou six tours h61
turaci ce matin que vous il l'a vu vite
un gars comme maxime qui dira hk tu
verras c'est facile non mais non médias
français doit être gagnant nettement
bon là il ya une menace quand tu fais
food & cie se faire tour 3 mai au f4
peut-être trois ou quatre ans hébergé
mathieu c'est bien dieu mais fou
jécistes aurait fuite
photo couleur un peu moi j'aurais dit
non et peut-être que la gagne c'est la
fin de mandat la nouvelle parce que le
pion est sûre h jusqu'à 1 est-ce que
lors aussi le roi aurait 27 oui mais tu
en as tant qu orange et 4 peut mettre le
roi c'est le truc mais infondée sein de
voir le chase qui est belle c'est lui
qui va nous dire si sa gamme est bon il
[Musique]
a toujours essayé de nous c'est un peu
surfait la besa trop faible est
peut-être le roi il arrive mambé 8
ouais mais je me situe mais quand tu
prends bessette si je fais foot b5
je ferai à 4 et j'ai créé le deuxième
choix j'en orane chaque côté layton 2e à
8 tu veux dire que roger 5 ha oui non tu
veux dire que j'aurais pas deuxième sur
place et ne ferait que je fasse trois b
6 3 à 5 et à 4 et je reviendrai en b 5
donc là il va avoir deux pioches qu'est
ce que c'est que ça nathan ya pas tout
raciste qui finit la partie genre sur le
flanc info bouger tu prends un chèque de
l'atome vous je prends du roi 8,1 faut
vite tu fais échec et tu bouffes après
ok bon être il reste encore une ou deux
parties 16 ans il reste
il reste deux parties je pense aux
pourceaux en fait je m'en fous juste
pour qu'il faille dont six gagnés
salavat les deux prochaines sa relance
un peu le match et un démenti sans
devoir nakache à foin non mais
franchement le score ne reflète
tellement pas le contenu mathieu al
alagi père fin je consomme bouffer les
ongles même pas un petit bout d'os pts
en 5 minutes samedi et comptant sur une
feuille partie mais le truc c'est que 3h
4 réfute mans lui moi aujourd'hui il ya
une très belle partie
mais bon c'était une prépa je pense à à
prague
non je suis point tel qu'un jour ça
aujourd'hui sur la jca t il a gagné une
partie importante maxime avec quelqu'un
tourage 4 était beau c'est par à vianne
on sent des pompes wagner il l'a
complètement des chiens maxime il avait
gagné contre great choc avec les noirs
gwenn il était mal venu avec les blancs
contre nez peau il était bien au 2ème
veulent ils jouent comme ça avec les
noirs ce geste 6 2 6
moi aussi j'aime bien ce double feinte
et au sommet et la joue ça je trouve ça
sympa c'est dynamique jamais réalisée
pendant je tape le plus bombée loeb peut
récupérer green flight search avec le
carélien mvl a enfin il est là
ouais mais en cela c'est peut-être un
bon coup de main mais carrière elle
n'est pas forcément mauvais ok
maintenant que ses pensées et 4 su
prendre à cava lui mais tout petit peu
moins bien ce genre de trucs kb24 tu me
tues champions tu marques un an des cats
échanger [ __ ] cas demain tu peux être
un peu mondain mais wells et je suis sûr
qu'il gagnera je veux plus dynamique qui
va leur être vraiment affûtés en
tactique en général un pas forcément ce
soir mais d'un point de vue général
mais il faut qu'ils prennent des cours
avec les dormants oui si c'est toi de
quiz rester ce truc là j'ai beaucoup
plus de gens regardez la redif sel ça
sort ce soir un peu nulle part que ben
non mais je sais pas en fait tout ça
s'arrange on sait même pas nous
affaiblir le roi mette un cavalier sur
des cinq après il 2005 arrive
franchement s'il gagne celle là ça
relance se maintient en plus il est fou
c'est quand tu domines est comme ça
bailly 2000 pari qu'avec alain cavalier
la tour aux prises les faits tu veux
ramener ta d'amendé c'est avec toi tu es
un cheveu il faut pas faire à 6h et
j'aime j'aime j'aime je devais dire à
sagem s'acheva liszt est validée et
franc f2 et peut-être des jeux gagnants
il va faire une sébastien joie hikaru
tant que c'est face à partir de changer
désolé c'est bien joué à cavalière
farine des fentes ou non et ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'il est hyper chiant à
battre à baisser il a le niveau de jeu
peut pas tenter des noms je vais faire
c'est un caillou cinq dates des 5 et
laisser la tour essaient d'aller mater
en force
je comprends pas qu'elle prend un trou
ya passe mais je prendrais tu prendre la
tour était en train de me dire y'a pas
un truc à 5 à la fin ouais on verra
c'est juste un as
non mais mais bon je pensais qu'il y
avait un truc avec tours 2 après mais je
n'arrive pas à le faire marcher jordan 8
dans le 6 avril au 2 tour de nommer des
dames français 50 puisque terrain il n'y
a pas d'étrangers de dames g4 serait
beau ça
je vais montrer va c'est une idée oui
enfin ça fait nulle part des shots en
fait voir un tel il va nous réfuté dans
le shop direct qui modifie enfin en
attendant c'est la partie mais l'a pas
fait en france ça que ça fait dam des
trois donc ton front des deux sets
gagnants fléchissent tu vas nous faire
baver 6 2 avait d'investi d'affaires
tournant autour de 8 où il faut agir ou
troisième voiture il ya peu de cas où
cet homme on d'un au 3è tour ou un fou
30 à 23 heures avant tout à l'heure
peut-être saint damase trois regarde
faut trois roues achat d'un match 3
c'est joli non mais là il va [ __ ] un
train nouvelle trêve donnant c'est plus
simple et je prends sur moi j'aime faire
ton projet de double échec
bon là on assiste à quelque chose on
n'aurait pas dit facile mais depuis que
messi n'est arrivé en fait c'est maxime
verizon gagnent ok bon moi je pensais
depuis ta blague douteuse bouquin jifar
c'est le nom giffords j'avais adoré le
livre d'ailleurs je dois d'abord ici la
fabuleuse histoire des champions
d'échecs
il est fantastique ce livre - on l'a mis
à l'essai un vieux dit léger la version
originale je l'avais je sais pas si je
le sais pas faire moi je vais manger un
avocat à la pause
j'ai tellement c'est ce que je fais un
truc bien souvent avocate enlève le
noyau et dans les 2 dans les deux
moitiés tu veux un peu d'huile d'olive
et tu manges à la cuillère t'as jamais
fait ça mais maintenant je me suis mis
un peu de temps avant la pause je ne
veux plus trou franchement cette équipe
d'athlètes ont mangé d'avocats tu
connais l'application pin desk pense
encore une fois c'est quoi le nom c'est
un truc de l'homme par exemple atypique
le tshirt tu peux le laisses tu le pin's
au ton bureau avait je ne puis n'est
rien du tout fait j'arrête
calme toi vas tu as tu eu la tâche n'en
verrais tu la tâche serait bon je
préfère quand même c'est bon je suis
mais après il est là ah ouais je vais
essayer c'est pas bête et parents tu
sais ça peut être cédée fois avec les
calculettes
à chaque fois tu dois ouvrir une fenêtre
la ferme et avec ça tu mets ta
calculette tu t'ouvres les autres trucs
et dans tous les cas la calculette et
devant assez bien ça je vais le prendre
j'ai découvert ça lien à l'essai bobin
merci face à ces des conseils ces
cadeaux les mathieu cornette s'il vous
plaît quoi pas aux attentes à mathieu
qu'il taille veille qu'il dit je lâche
les scoops y écrit quoi qui peut
s'asseoir il a fait 280 parties en 2019
il dit qu'il est un athlète mais je
pense que bogdan ali qui a fait plus
vraiment désolé donc
il a fait des quatre essais mais il est
encore bien oui c'est là où c'est moi
qui lis pasqua il se passe quoi nacala
il se passe quoi est ce qui se fait pas
dominé de a à z par le joueur américain
l'a 7 ans régine qui est sinon c'est
qu'on aille à une masse de matin d'un
bond il le voit mais c'est ce que les
dix reprises puis on prend ta ble ssé
cas d'échec la france et 6 mais s'il
fait d'emprunt du fesf et d'un prend
juste tourner un jeu de m6 kato corps
non dan scott
eye for her feria fois six mois je suis
capable de me prendre leur fils est
pourquoi être plus l'autre match
d'aujourd'hui
non mais ça j'ai pas aimé c'est quand
même mieux
oui mais pourquoi remettre une structure
à l'endroit quand elle à l'envers louis
le pieux il est vraiment faible mais il
va agir il a 24 compte trois stérile je
veux jouer mon 4 contre 3 de l'autre
côté pourquoi l'animateur la même qu'à
rallier ses cinq fauves et cette épreuve
4 gens sérieux qui j'ai vu un homme un
truc sauf les chevaux qui m'a fait rire
combien de partis le grand maître fear
c'est alexander fer le brésilien comme
un parti l'ont longue at-il perdu en
2010 9 qui firent fier mais j'ai battu à
l'armée j'ai vu ce qu'ils essaient cinq
tours des cinq fois ci soit et je pense
que ça devrait aller pour les mains avec
à tf2 qui traîne il a perdu 32 parties
longues en une année pour un grand m il
demandait si c'était pas un record
serait boxer encore magnus il va dire
ouais je peux faire meilleur encore que
toi l'année prochaine ne fait 34 défaite
32 défaites pour un grand maître dans
une année en partie lent que c'est à lui
c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup même pour
moi ce serait beaucoup n'ont pas fait
février-30 stationnement tour au cices
j'aurais jamais joué des quartiers
francis
faire quoi et pourquoi si si abc cap
calme total 1 mais du côté des canaux
tour torrent et que je cas ici 5 à les
deux mois d'attentes entourant les
qualités quatre avocats et des quatre
direct moi je ferais cahiers les cats
ont raflé chien mais bon contrôle ce
matin général nicolas fléchit pas qu'ils
aient prend ses six faux bessette yato
prend des six comprend un f3 à croix
c'est pas vrai ce que tu fasses un
bienfait retour aux deux études déplace
à tours c'est bien joué je l'aurais pour
l'homme il avait voulu faire caler dans
lequel cinq est heureux de ce débat
inquiète processus aille maintenant il
aura fou des quatre peut-être à jour sur
deux des six taureaux 2 qui a été 4 1
c'était un peu mieux encaisser six soirs
il veut quoi x 6 mai fois à six taureaux
un anneau match comme en bas vous qu'il
prend pas fou bessette qui est des cas
tu reviens et en même temps prendrait
six phases dire sur quoi tu prends pas
un pion peut-être se dit tu vas trouver
un bon coup cherche aussi n'y a pas
mieux je visitais bien trop de conseils
trop de groupes trop de concept je veux
faire pousser un intermédiaire je sais
pas à quoi ça sert on prend un but on va
voir mais pour moi c'est des connexions
à deux pas pendant ces six et ils sont
donc tu refuses il ya des cavaliers 5 à
calculer est vrai que si tu fais foulbé
7 à la fin ils veulent dr cette dernière
5 laprise prises pour b737 un sapin je
comprends production beaucoup plus fort
que nous parce que moi qui ai français
si ce fait je réfléchis même pas mais je
te dis c'est pour ça qu'ils sont plus
forts que nous a simplement fait
ça je ne considère pas ce coup
n'appartient pas à la position tourer
ainsi si ça appartient la pression juste
nous l'eau n'y aurait même pas pensé
mais cavalier seul c'est ce que j'ai dit
f4 peut-être ces cinq ans et 5 c'est
moche ces problèmes perdent un peu mais
si je fais j'ai trois il veut quoi il
veut c 5 ou un truc qui fera f4 sur
karen et live
kévani n'en est plus un bref ça c'était
peut-être un peu débiles aussi tourer
inquiète bref cette quasi-absence hymne
à la joie mais a wife et ouais comme ça
tu prends pas des six sur échec et je
vais à ce comité bref 4 ouais ouais mais
alors à temps pour ces 8 fc 4 ans et 8 c
4 des 5
ça doit tenir à temps mais ça tu peux
pas prendre de 8.9 pouces et 2 6 pouces
et 2 c 3 tu pourras pas tous les gardes
ouais je peux garder que ah mais oui je
suis deg
eh bien il va s'en sortir on peut la
joue pas comme cela non ça là non jarry
dirai ce que va faire foule à b4 longo à
50 prend b3 fou b4 fou à quatre coups
des six mois avant lui mais bon ça c'est
complètement nul quoique nul et nul
n'est pas si simple la structure est pas
si propre tu veux pas faire le truc de
naître le roi là et de tout défendre
avec un fou ces pauses à celle là où
s'est posé à celle là oui puisqu'en fait
ouverte à un problème si tu fais g5 ta
structure est pourri ouais mais tu t'en
fous est-ce que tu t'en fous tant que ça
oui je peux mettre un pur angers qatar
angers 6e fois f5 moyens ça tape qui
fait nul n'y en a pas qu'un
mala il a raison il faut qu'il la joue
edward g iii je pense toute façon quoi
d'autre jeffrey j'ai cinq ans et arrive
à faire j'ai 5 g 4 flèches 3 ça va être
nul en russie
comment tu ne m'empêche pas juste mais
tu vas prendre au jeu des quêtes ou quoi
même en droit d'être om illico à maxime
se gagnent ou c'est nul ça mathieu
seigneur tu t'enflammes mais c'est nul
tu as juste pas d'idées
slash à une seconde de rajouts faut des
8es après je monte le roi un même à
faire [ __ ] échec tu dois t'en terroir
4 3 3 ou 4 et envoyé pioncer mais c'est
le bon pions lâche un façon de la faire
re 4 sinon et wyeth c'est peut-être
gagnant froid qui veut attenter à ses
pas idiot il gagne intel pour 1 3 1
on attend il laissait faire un truc à
your wife 3 maintenant il préfère avoir
le fond des 8 mai peut-être vers l'iss
est nul mais dangereux bah oui re 3 ici
il faut quand même le faire trois des
quatre rôles respectifs et roanne à
mayroy des quatre oies des quêtes mais
seul coup de façon intéressante sous la
tente à un moment donné mais notamment
20 joueurs wife cette donnée g5 à partir
oui ça j'ai compris alors ça doit
annuler ce que le roi revient sur le
plus oui mais quel autre plan oui ce que
je comprends pas c'est pourquoi il ne
fait pas du tout dangereux c'est la
soupe à la grimace
côté français revenu 1 il paraît qu'il
est hyper bon une minute non c'est pas
ça pour maintenance et l inverse un
hamac ont fait c'était l'autre en fait
qui était vachement voilà c'est nul ils
arrêtent de purger six durant ces huit
le four en f 5 et c'est fini une
antienne mini-boss by me pose tout de
suite pas de suite dont mathieu qui part
pour la mini pause qui va manger
nous on fait quoi de jambes et une pub
on se met bien c'est dommage pour moi
c'est parce qu'il meurt il meurt à moins
de la enfin il meurt à -2 il vient y
vient à - 2 alors que franchement sur le
scénario
rien que la deuxième partie qui perd ou
il est gagnant et vous pouvez faire le
point est vrai d'un point de vue général
ces problématiques quoi d'avoir un tel
ou tel écart alors qu'ils étaient il
était vraiment pas loin il était
vraiment pas loin je vous mets une
longue pub dont on a le secret sur jazz
comme france fait une longue pub dont on
a le secret pâques c'est parti donc les
pubs sont de sortie et je vous met la
petite musique malheureusement n'a pas à
l'écran de pause à cause à cause comme
vous l'avez vu des problèmes pour les
caméras
mais on va se retrouver on va se
retrouver très vite
voilà le score reflète vraiment pas les
parties jouées les tambours de l'enfer
où je reste avec vous sans entendre de
l'enfer un petit coup de tampon dans
l'enfer mais pas pour cinq minutes je
reviens vite je vais faire je mangeais
une clémentine vaut bien un petit coup
de tampon à les partis tambour de
l'enfer
[Musique]
je
mais les gains suis venu vous vous
sauvez des pub d'enfer et on à mathieu
qui nous fait beaucoup de mal au fond
ouais c'est génial quoi et amy tu es
mieux au coin quoi sur le canal ouais
c'est bon ouais moi j'achète des petite
clémentine jaffa déjà pas je suis
heureuse mais c'est bon c'est bon c'est
bon c'est plein de vitamine c c'est bien
la vitamine c c'est bon pour l'immunité
est tous avec le corona qui arrive on
est on est bien on est bien faut faire
fuller faux vitamine c du coup preuve
ils ont fini 4es courantes à savoir ça a
prague j'ai pas trop suivi honnêtement
le tournoi de prague et du pool des
partages voilà enfin la planète
revisitée fait rougir
il est ils ont vu les cinq ex-aequo à 5
sur 9
il est bon on a quand même pire ou déjà
ni confirme mais en plus la façon qu'ils
perdent est parti c'est souvent hyper
naïf donc il ya une marge de progression
assez énorme et à l'aéro flottent çà
ajout madoff qui avait tu sa retient
étonnant non comme une perf à 2840 en
route chez ses gains à l'autre certains
ont quand même de certains résultats
quoi l'impression que c'était la
révélation de l'année et je vois cette
partie par avion
moi je l'appelle paravent perso mais il
a refait le h4 et tour h4 la nouveauté
mais c'est une amélioration de mardi
en ce qui concerne la nationalité
française de fil rogers honnêtement on
n'est pas au courant
on sait pas ce qui se passe entre un
rapport au ministère de l'intérieur
matures par encore après ses beaux fils
il se passe juste au rien c'est possible
pourquoi tous m'ont dit que regione ça
va te piquer le niveau tarifs auto temps
franchement moi si c'est 300 euros ça me
choque pas chaque semaine ils s'arrêtent
au dessus trois sauts et je sais pas
c'est des fois les kickstarter site au
tout début
c'est pas si cher
après ce soir il y aura aussi quand même
très important à ce que va faire fable
libye au tournoi quoi de belote
non mais vraiment c'est clémentine
ça y est ça rebloqué ça fait que bloquer
les caméras en dessous donc on n'a pas
d'informations importantes pour le
moment est-ce que je stream ce soir
écoute je pense pas parce que ça va
finir par le match là il ya encore un
peu plus d'une heure et demie de
compétition
donc je pense pas je ne pense pas
je ne pense pas bref un superbe
engouement pour ce match honnêtement je
regarde un peu celle du monde qui suit
j'ai pas il n'y a pas énormément de
monde qui sait motiver pour suivre ce
match franchement mathieu oui bon il
n'ya pas y'a pas un énorme engouement du
public pour ce match dans le live web
sur les lier un peu tous les lives des
tu as aussi de duchess comme sur les
autres langues et c'est pas il n'y a pas
grand monde qui s'échauffent et pour
pour ce match là c'est un peu bizarre en
fait cette conviction de speechless j'ai
l'impression que plus les années passent
plus elle perd en mais est-ce que c'est
palette rugby moderne
la première année en général les trucs
marché après il en place oui et non il
faudrait un fort à un coup de fouet à
cette compétition
mais après est-ce que ça a pas fait du
mal qui est plus m'amuse je pense
qu'aussi oui bien sûr clairement mais à
mais je pense aussi plus généralement
que ouais voilà les gens les gens sont
moins sont moins hype et par cette
compétition qui lui un qu'ils ne l'ont
été et aussi la ya peut-être eu une trop
grande attente entre les demi finales et
la finale
je savais même pas qu'on savait que oui
mémoire est là la demi finale a lieu en
mi décembre et il y avait écrit la date
de la finale to be decideix déchets pas
eu plein de tournois plein de trucs
l'approach s league machin et ça a été
repoussée repoussé repoussé repoussé
savent passe maintenant c'est vrai que
c'est un petit peu à contretemps pour
une compétition qui était en 2019
à mon avis un talon sarr joue sajou un
nom quand trois plus un ça va jouer une
heure voici qui encore dans le match 1 2
points d'écart à 3 il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'idées mais c'est pas complètement con
c'est une écossaise à couleurs inversées
avec enfin l'équivalent de 1 à 6
il veut jouer la finale tu as lu vida
qui peut être aussi que la prod
classique fait un peu d'ombré à la
compétition oui c'est très possible
c'est vrai que la prod classique ça
permettait assez intense et c'est pas
fini et le mieux reste à venir enfin
tout cas le match france- new york ça me
hype de folie personnellement mathieu
oui on va avoir comme je le disais un
peu plus tôt un 8e de finale 1 8e de
finale assez alléchant qui nous attend
on sera opposée à l'équipe new yorkaise
emmené par hikaru ce sera
ce sera très intéressant et très très
serré à mon avis et c'est en norvège la
finale en plus oui ce sera à oslo donc x
4 qui maintient la pression sur le
cavalier sait si c'est peut-être un coup
comme b5 peut être envisageable mais il
veut me sur enfer qu'il pense et si ces
efforts c'est aberrant à 4 qui décide de
faire fou 17 pour tuer le clouage ouais
ça peut échanger ans et 6 puis échangé
en d4 et les blancs une meilleure
structure de pions mais les noirs vont
pouvoir faire ces cinq à tout moment et
caro qui propose nulles et de nuls et
acceptez donc ils kaouki comme tout à
l'heure en perles et blanc mathieu ouais
mais il s'en fout oui moi aussi
est-ce qu'il va changer
ah ouais c'est plutôt pas mal passé dans
quelques italienne il ya eu la finale où
il a perdu mais bon c'était pas à cause
de l'ouverture
attends moi je pense qu'il doit
continuellement jeu qu'il est mieux dans
ce domaine
est-ce qu'il a eu le temps de course de
regarder entre souvent ils ont là ils
réussissent à le faire un parti ça à
froid hip hop c'est un truc de fou mais
cgg analyse est vite fait ça on est à
tout analyser le jour il a joué entre
qui j'avais jamais vu style et ça m'a
choqué et là j'imagine dans la caméra il
doit faire jouer à y réfléchir
il est la raison là on a un petit peu
l'accablent ouais il est la regarde est
ce que je fais tout fou il faut
franchement ap plus essosso il est
dégoûté
est-ce que tu femmes ont alors clair
genre à regarder entre gens au moins ce
tamis à l'aps qui se joue tout le temps
de sa wii après peut-être que si on veut
te faire une petite pause 3 minutes pour
pour souffler fort qu'on demande à
maxime d'ailleurs ce qui fait
ce que lui la jouer ces matches on les a
jamais joué en réalité non mais je
connais pas bien mais juste j'ai vu
qu'il a joué sa un des drames de ces
derniers matches et ça m'avait j'avais
jamais vu ce type d en fait je ferai
c'est intéressant mais j'ai pas les cinq
mutins ce genre de truc c'est le samu
avec mon ordi demi heure ça ça pas grand
chose
et du coup ce que j'aime bien les noirs
peut-être mais j'aime bien le foot et 5
entre les deux pions mans après les
laisse pas la dame me ranger 4 c'est
normal qu'à maxi qui regardent pas
rentrer même quand il ya des grosses
puisque des fois il ya des gros tu as
bien sûr au niveau joué que ça voilà
près tenir sa perte d'énergie il
faudrait que tu es quelqu'un qui regarde
pour toi la nuit ouais c'est pareil
c'est pas évident parce que le match et
quand même long et a besoin de te garder
l'énergie tu as besoin de tenir jusqu'au
but lettre il va avoir beaucoup de
parties sales trucs que tu peux faire
baisser si quelqu'un te fies juste une
info très rapide
ouais mais regardez par toi même je
pense que t'as pas le majin mais un même
toit pour commenter pas eu besoin
d'aller manger un petit peu grosse loupe
rangée de l'équipe ranger 4
j'y crois pas trop hein parce qu'après
quatre ans j'ai quatre dames prends tu
vas faire la gueule quand même pas quoi
penser de cette pause de mathieu je
bosse pour ça que je dis rien je crie
aussi j'aurais tendance sommes pas
visuellement les noirs ça va mais ça que
le roi est un peu faible
donc là il a moins de pions devant lui
voit nue
les blancs faut qu'ils trouvent une idée
juste envie de jouer f3 calme et prise
bassa'a peut soulager un peu la défense
adverse et 5
à défaut de talent qui peut jeter 5,5
force les changes c'est bien joué
clouage mahina a souvent un fils ici pas
négligeable mais bon je pense maintenant
coup comme tous rêvent 7
ça devrait suffire non et au rêve cette
dé 5,3 fuite et tu veux dire que tu
joues en plus sur le pion ses sets et un
peu sur le roi damas 7 27 qu'est ce
qu'on fait sur tour à tour eu tous
rêvent de tours sète à tour à y faire
échec c'est ça je vais là des rouages de
l 2 ça a l'air pas mal ça parlait lors
de la finale et mieux ce qu'on prend 6,7
et dames 10 tamoul à ses douches qu'un
tour 7 ce projet que faire
je sais pas pour qui c'est louche en
réalité je ne sais pas louche pour
wesley mais moi je joue le jeu dame g6
d'abord nom pourrait fuiter 90 euros
c'est possible ça aurait été mieux mais
là ça doit quand même aller pour les
blancs malgré tout on a quand même
beaucoup d'activités les tours sur la
côtière sont peut-être pas mal du tout
mais têtue au f4 f5 g4 et déjà c'est la
tour et faire un duo sur la deuxième map
prochain coup tu fais ta recette c'est
sur wii
après il faut pas se précipiter trop sur
le pion c'est parce que les noirs
peuvent jouer à quatre taureaux b5
j'ai l'impression de maxi 1000 ans il a
un il est en différé son live ouais
maxime est absent quillan sûr on se
parle mais à quoi ou joly à 10 minutes
ouais c'est très bizarre je sais pas
pourquoi c'est vraiment étrange affaire
il a défendu avec l'autre comme sa b2
est vraiment faible maintenant mais je
suis pas encore je b3 et au 17 mai tu
vas te prendre pour b 2 à 4 la classique
réussir à tout échange et ben il va
réussir à tout est changé mais il est
blond normalement peuvent se retrouver
avec un 3 contre 2 comme ben ça suffit
pas normalement non tant baisse des six
c'est ça que je pense c'est d'allumer
que je pensais il tombe elle si c'était
arrivé entre conte de noël où tu joue
évidemment un mais perd 3,3 bon il veut
même pas compte d'eux mais n'a pas tort
sont ils allés pas le gagner il veut pas
il veut pas perdre trop de temps c'est
pas faux
j'y avais pas pensé il rejoue ce avec
les blancs non mais il a dû inverser
comment ça et bien versé tu dire qu'ils
veulent inverser un coup dans la
première il alors une autre idée je
viens je vois pas trop l'intérêt de la
production du fer de l'équivalent de la
sisqa délit nous il ya peu de cas des 4
mai dans sa halle à particulier
honnêtement je vois pas non au live il
faut français si j'ai quatre quel point
ça aide mais tu fais vite d'un match 4 1
non mais ça va tout à fait pour pour les
normes seraient bien ques les îles en
regagne une pour revenir à portée de
fusil quoi vraiment sur le téléphone au
nom desquels n 1 ça pour ça peut-être on
ne sait pas on n'est pas sur téléphone
g4 est ce que je te dis d'un match 4
ouais mais ça fait nul la coop y en a
deux un coureur ag2r un truc dernière 3
ouais super ambitieux avec les blancs
quand même à fait normal
comment ça marche c'est plus un coup la
remercie c'est pas sûr facile de se
rappeler en plus moi ça me dérange pas
mais juste
je joue pas ça non f5 je pense que c'est
le coup elle cinq alertes roth donc sept
reprises d'abord nous mais f5
parce que ce qui faisait 5 avec effroi
dollar qu'on s'assoit et balance signaux
d'air finalement il nourrit ica
sagittaire signe de feu l'air nourrit le
fenouil ibo nice on n'a aucune chance
donc trees prises angers 4 puis on prend
ce qu'on peut je souffre en ce 2 et à te
faire [ __ ] et un abat oui c'est mon
prochain beau mais tu vas je fous b2b
oui c'est un foot est roi dieu
monfort en d3 et être bien placé
également ce que tu fais d'un projet
canopia oui si on prend ces deux pour ne
pas perdre courage à vous français de
choc toi f4 c'est pas idiot non futur
restaurant g4 et je devrai retour et
fuite
il sera à tourcoing f3 prix f3 priseur
trois prises f3 et dames f6 échec
il y aura peut-être des 4 bon il faut
quand même rentrer dans le truck
encaissé c3 et tu as très bien avec une
rare mais oui c'est un choix
catastrophique 10 kg de fruits c'est
fini rex 3 taux refi tempo allez allez
wesley a le joueur le joueur philippin
là qui est en train de remonter
mathieu c'est l'un des deux gagnants
juste non foulbé 2h30 pour un temps la
marche pas ça peut être gagnant euros 3
tours 3 2 temps 3 foot français joue
comme on sait ce qu'on a à perdre et un
nom peut pas tout prendre trois quarts
damage trois dames france et 3 encaissés
sûrement ces deux ans encore mais même
je vois pas comme ça
tant qu'à faire courber un bon retour
non madame france et deux échecs je
trouve bon bah si tu peuvent si tu peux
dire dans le français 3 ça c'est sûr
mais tu peux a fait retour à deux pour
tomber deux kops anomymes 15,2 bon mais
ça me prend des quatre ne prendrait
qu'un taureau trop c'était pour yves
pour est un mythe en c2 aussi un quart
en tout cas ça fait ça fait 7 à 8
mathieu de l'état j'ai envie de te dire
c'est pas de saint clair ça
sept à huit non c'est cette source c'est
sur cet essai ta vie tu sais qui c'est
harry roselmack
non c'est pas sur tf1 par un truc comme
ça avec nikos aliagas je sais pas qui à
70 7 à 8
triste harry roselmack
on ne sait pas qui a gagné du coup au
départage visiblement autant salle donc
donc donc donc on est on est sur le
match et c'est plus serré qu'il n'y
paraît aof - visuellement là je pense
que les blancs sont mieux mais après le
contrôle d'état ce ton fouillé kemp aouf
en d6 m'acquittera l'autre présentation
dakar en process ligue en speech et
chaque village qui faisait qu'ils
adorent et les mauvais fou à 21,4 paraît
tellement qu'on puisse maintenant
j'aurais glissé 5 avec intel c'est vrai
que c'est bizarre façon b 6 à 5 aux gay
tc genre de réflexe tomber un cadavre
dit anéanti court terme c'est pas si
grave estime donc way of heroes déjà
qu'ils gagnent price
mais il peut arriver vraiment très très
vite à haut niveau affirme que la wii la
cam des grosses grosses lacunes un prix
d'efforts pour gagner encore un tournoi
il avait été bon à vichy il gagne haut
la rue saint pierrois montre-moi la cave
j'ai envie de voir mais je sais pas si
j'ai déjà riche de la gagne je la perds
je suis tout ce que je peux mais
j'appelle très souvent mais d'ailleurs
pourquoi il essaie pas de régler ce
problème c'est que c'est quand même un
truc hallucinant
ouais mais c'est pas c'est vraiment pas
évident régler wibang afin qu'ils ont
quand même oui il fait une tête bizarre
ma fille fait ça car une fois qu enfin
pourquoi il a perdu son pion aussi
bêtement demande hervé 4 ça arrive mais
il est vraiment au regard des issues ici
rien il va il va chialer bientôt
franchement il est proche de chialer ne
regarde il rougit les pommettes rougies
ce le tan ne tient plus mathieu non mais
sérieux regarde il faut se méfier car
[Musique]
avoue qu'il a pu tout à fait la même
couleur qui a qu'à quelques quelques
minutes quand il rougit comme une tomate
elle powell tout cas se domine vraiment
le match sow est dominant qu'est ce que
c'est c'est bien joué cinq intermédiaire
caméra ça fait n'importe quelle caméra
servant trois fautes 3 un tube peur d'un
clown presque plein
tata khadija senez de me2 va faire
d'amadou dames c'est vrai et juste fou 3
n'a qu'à un cas qui craque
bon me 8,8 étonnant de la part du joueur
américain qui nous a habitué à mieux
mathieu dans cette compétition et que
des corps intermédiaires supportable
voilà c'est fini mais je jouais l'autre
avec ses cousins dans leur idylle tabac
c'est une vraie pièce c'est vrai qu'on
entend on entendra qu'à pleurer derrière
[Rires]
les cinq reprises f5 ça va faire mal
aussi
qu'est ce qu'il fait là fin gersois
sérieux de 9,5 ce son seul piège est en
train de se prendre pour un qui marchait
pas il y avait cet échec qui se posent
et si on prend 1,4 à f 6 volailles blind
les jardins 9,5 à vii
ça fait main sur palm pre mier g5 et
damages cet écart et ligier cinq des six
sinon y avoir assisté des six semaines
plus fort tous gagnants à 3 way va lui
faire cet échec quand même et qu'il y
ait cinq jours c'est la même ravi sa
main ouais ça a l'air de marcher
ouais c'est jouer allez allez wesley
qu'est ce qu'il est prêt si wesley quand
même quand il veut franchement ce match
sa barbe est de 53 minutes
s'il ya 3 1 des jeunes on ice t il ce
fait n'a qu'à maka qui souhaitait monter
un bon échange en train de verture ce
qui est bien et va se reprendre pour la
haye joue comme ça c'est normal on joue
des saints étaient les femmes est
repartie de karwan and build et ses
griffes choc qui avait une première
ajoute cette dernière
moi j'ai joué une vieille partie mur tu
as avec les blancs contre - là très
longtemps il m'avait déjà juste 3 way en
face précurseur 1,2 après la quinta
fesci s'est déjà qu'avec le pian 1,4
sais pas si tu rates depuis un an 1,3 ça
doit pas non plus être monstrueux tout
cas moi ce que ce que je te dis c'est
que nakaya pas longtemps il sort une
vidéo je suis 3300 search askham c'est
vrai bon bah tout 3188 copains je
retiens quand même de perdre 112 points
socke est en train de faire redescendre
la cassure terre là il est en train de
lui montrer quand même qui est plus fort
habite faut prendre cette part est à
oublier vite et après tu fait qu'elle
ait des cinq autres champs c'est hyper
important pour moi et c'est là prendre
le lead si on veut qu'ils gagnent ce
match mathieu ça ça va passer par là
il faut absolument qu'ils marquent
quelle est cette fois on peut on peut
pas venir danser là un petit peu sur les
cases du joueur américain français 3 des
fois tu peux je fous prendre seuls 3 il
faut compter 5
on va voir bon sinon tu fais simplement
un 5 à 7 ans vient de pain français
serait peut-être pas si vieux que ça
mais bon mais je pense que je ferais
français prend moins chez quasiment soit
j'ai joué des dragons accéléré et
j'étais content de faire ce coup campion
et il le fait il le fait mathieu il est
inarrêtable damas cinq îles monstrueux
il est monstrueux ce soir le parce que
pris triste ou b deux hommes d'être
autonome enfin je pense vous prendre
stade français 3 est pas une idée y
tient bien sûr que non je faisais donne
des trois pays la protégée de pions on
peut pas faire un petit plouf sinclar a
eu quatre des dames 1 3 défaut on sait
très bien joué il développe ses pièces
et là vraiment tous les coups du tennis
à wesley un petit coup de dé veloppement
sogood jeu qui montre que si on n'a pas
vu la même débutants ils dominent
il est mené de quatre points contre le
cours du jeu et et il remonte comme ça
franchement ouest gso et grands ce soir
mathieu non messieurs buses theillet des
dames à six qui peuvent faire mal
il ya des fous 17,6 aux siens sa
gertrude j'aurais même pas pensé ouais
bah maintenant on y passe
spy jours non il va jouer quatre chemins
se sont pas du tout fou 17 ici à mon
avis c'est un courant à non il ya foot
est à présent avec cette parlant pendant
fausse alerte qu'est-ce qu'il dit maxime
attention à vous casser le retour du
bâton
non je pense juste qu'il est maintenant
j'aime bien damas quatre empêche de l'a4
tu m'as
de prendre des fois pas faire dame ces
deux dames des trois pelotons style ces
peuples mais abaisse attendent près je
précise d'abord mais c'est pape l'autre
en étant la dame de foy ça doit être la
personne point bas je pensais toujours
illustrant fille très beaux atouts les
poules à deux ou qu'on a perdu des
points perdus des aires de pique se joue
bien on prévoit plus tout près padam g3
la maîtrise ige cadres a mieux c'est
d'un autre j'aurais qu'est ce qui fait
je comprends rien là je vais faire je
vais faire [ __ ] sept mois ça c'est
bien ça je suis là où je comprends
revient à f3 je comprends rien là qui
avait fait dame ces deux dames des trois
sites de téléchargements de jeux faire
d'amd cette dame c'est le voilà voilà
c'est ça mon et cela c'est un amour s
les idées si je fais le tour des 1
j'ai pas d'idée mathieu j'encaisse à
deux je t'envoie qui ont alors la gueule
ouais ok on échange c'est bien mais si
tu prends degré mains d'un rêve 5
je reviens nom d'homme des trois tours
trois tomes français cut raté aussi
courageux que ça pourquoi pas
franchement au patro ferraille et
détroit je comprends à temps pour eux
deux les tours d un vous prendre quand
même ces 3 et 4 [ __ ] bah oui qu'elle
prend 1,4 après pourra rajouter je
partais lui pris à temps c'est bien joué
et on prend les trois points f4 prise
est prise en d3 mathieu il faut prendre
et 6 c'est un vin c'est un coup assez
extraordinaire ça marche c'est
extraordinaire ce que fait vrai c'est le
tour je which way ton jeu 8 était par le
chant roman
dam des cinq dans machete tour j'ai sept
tours 7
c'est maintenant la mâche 8 secondes
qu'est-ce que ses confrères je peux pas
faire le cinquième cinq montées droit de
biozone je comprends rien on peut aussi
d'amélia vidal f7 si l'échangé tout dame
prend 2,6 d'un point à 2 je suis tout
proche cette fois c'est d'amener cette
dame f7 direct et la finale gêné d'être
gagnante
ah oui dans ma tête c'est oui oui non
non on comprend maintenant peut-être fc
inquiet dams et si stocker et g5
oui j'ai cinq petit mais oui mathieu il
va le maté mais oui mathieu voilà qu'est
ce que c'est bien joué
qu'est ce que c'est bien jouer mathieu
ne me prends cette froide un français
trois dames f2 d'alger 3 h trois ans il
est en train de tout lui faire et la
finale des as pour effet peu d'hommes
aux extraordinaires extraordinaire
nature exonérant mathieu yellow il y
avait garé 6-1 et 6-2 1-6 et demi deux
ans et demi on tirer la gueule à ce
moment là et depuis il ya eu il ya eu
trois nuls et 5 victoires de wesley qui
hantera vraiment de faire respecter la
loi et un écart ou fait des choix
bizarres à deux pics tadis haut domine
il domine vraiment une personne le
poison
comme gagner une can non non non non non
non non on ne retourne pas nos avions
sont en plein match mathieu je voulais
un match chanteuse rsa est intéressant
quand tu auras plus 5 pour wesley
peut-être on vérifiera une eye fait mal
wesley maka qui tire la gueule on n'a
pas les images mais on le sent j'essaye
j'essaye de récupérer la kbwala on voit
où il tire la gueule
il tire la gueule à l'ouest mais aussi
qui fait la gueule je ne mène que d'un
point contre un joueur qui n'appartient
pas à cette compétition
on a rarement vu
so dominé de cette manière c'est assez
violent
je vous prie instance étonnant release
aux lampions mathieu hun kim jacques
heydecker donc 5 kg 5 maintenant il est
vieux il ya encore mieux jouer à la main
chez extraordinaire le joueur d'origine
philippine qui en train de 4,1 de marché
sur cette compétition mathieu il avait
su tisser voit son parcours il n'a pas
battu baky ça c'est sûr mais il avait
accusé il a battu des joueurs je sais
plus qui l'a battu c'est a trop
longtemps mais il a gagné contre des
mecs assez fort le boîtier est nouvelle
il a battu lvs je crois bien mais nous
couper lâcher parce qu'il a dit encore
un compte commun qui même à quel scoop
et le sait il n'a jamais regarder koh
lanta de sa vie vous avez une il a battu
arthémy afrique et et qui était un
joueur très dangereux
lvl bon il y avait tous les meilleurs en
gros tous les deux pour justice mme
sinclair se peut un peu mieux pour les
blancs quand même car 5e bientôt b1
il va revenir on sait qu'à t'inquiète
pas
[ __ ] d'avancé 8 et à tours en 1 8 pour
le moment excuse-moi meilleur palmarès
des carouges et pas développé deux
pièces
c'est pas complètement faux tu peux pas
me blessy sa cause qu'est processus
menace cavaliers le seul 701
il ya beaucoup de problèmes mathieu il
veut je vais 6 le tour des chantiers
puis on se situe à l'écharpé si ça peut
lui faire tomber un intermezzo
franchement fait fait - une statue pour
fêter tous il n'a pas de coût non un
prêt à évoquer les fuites
mais il ya ya pas iem pas sera pas du
jeu sur canal+ le gaouyat pas sérieux
c'est fantastique qu il te montrer une
action de foot et hu devaient comprendre
ses rives but ou pas but ah oui ici mais
je rappelais pas l'avouer j'avais vu
dans un un truc c'était un pari encore
plus tôt russie 5 4 mathieu f4 et f5 au
prochain je vais être mat et mathieu tu
vas essayer
5 il fait à mes recettes iront y donne
des pions il rend plus les coûts mathieu
25 août au matin d'un 9,5
c'est un pion mathieu y aussi non pas
lors des quatre aussi éventuellement
nong des cups d'un f3 c'est partant
faire dame g7 en suspens car g3 wave ou
choquette
on t'a tamm ha tamm h un chevreuil
d'arrêt 5 5 ou 9 5 - c'est le coq rôti
plus mignonne allez faut pas gaffer
wesley il ya ces quatre ans prises
d'ailleurs qu'on a peu vu
mais mon tour des huit auteurs ces
quatre c'est du vent et mathieu temps
des huit américains et noir s'en sort
convient
arrête ça michael jeu pour dunkerque
cette partie mathieu qui pour nakache
cette partie non mais j'ai envie qui
oppose un peu qui sait la tête sous
l'eau il faut la mine non mais il a été
soulevé lors que sa tête ne va plus du
tout être sous l'eau et tu vas regretter
qu'ils soient aussi proches au score il
est vraiment bon gras est il vraiment
bull est donc au bout d'un moment si
ouest et à 2,3 points d'avancé avant les
pulls est on prend est-ce que os clés du
jeu à cet entraînement oui ce type est
un athlète je vais hier soir 200 g de
haricots verts ale il faut se faut se
battre à fond là mathieu dembélé les
chroniqueurs phonak a ravi les ports vga
et paient les points d'accueil pour la
carène cherchent chacun festive s'ils
avaient lu est pour l'accueil pour la
cafa c'est pas grave tu veux être pour
n'a qu'à pas ce qu'ils veulent et pour
nike a pas du tout je vais être fournis
qu'à parce qu'il a peur de tout et elle
est repartie au nom un an
ah non j'ai cru qu'ils perdraient une
pièce non non ça fout davis a souhaité
qu'ils n'avaient pas vu non plus non il
n'est pas lui mais bon il a le droit
d'être un peu d'avoir un peu de réussite
à un moment donné il faut agir l'autre
envahi tout le long pouget 5 d'hommes
mais l achat de biens bien ça record
mais c'est peut-être quand même
sceptique et un usain bolt en couloir on
a perdu les calmes et il va pouvoir
faire tourner à 315 normalement ici
justement mauvaise impression
je suis deg
tu auras 8 8 e 6 et leurs hommes à se
cacher
c'est quoi le plan donc la tour dire
c'est pas que talent show a même pas
trop bon je suis rabattu mathieu col à
un couloir 5
c'est un beau mouvement c'est un bon
christophe lemaitre crocovert 5 mai
couloir 5 qui est un peu faible en du
sempa de la coi qui ont défoncé ah non
mais ça c'est hyper intéressant que sa
structure est la théorie elle a évolué
selon pensais que ça allait facilement
points noirs et après il n'est pas si
simple pourtant à un temps plus long
terme les gt2 nouveau pour wesley la
part d'un supporter du psg quoi ça
change de club
tout tout tout les je suis bordelais
avis un tueur je souffre en bourse ou
non mais t'as remarqué le nombre de
personnes qui sont devenues supporters
du psg en l'espace d'une dizaine
d'années et donc le truc un peu nouveau
c'est que les blancs en droit de jouer à
quatre laissez la case f4 sous la carte
b4 par seconde et c'est pas si grave ce
qu'après tant fait rêver en tête par
exemple qui est pour le psg aussi
maintenant c'est quoi c'est quoi ce
délire aucune raison juste c'est lé
gagnant quand il mais pour lyon maxime
et pour lyon mais il n'est pas dit on du
tout oui j'arrive à pâtir pied pour le
psg aussi payer pas pour tout le monde
quand même
il est pur à londres il déteste et je
suis au courant de son petit paris je
pense je vais pas le dire dans le chat
mais il était assez beau bordeaux ça
qu'on joue bien contre marseille c'est
bien qu'ils font comme seule page tant
les bleus oui ça y est vous avez voulu
faire tilter la toussaint pensions n'ont
mangé à la gorge je suis plutôt paris
que marseille
tu peux pas être pour bordeaux et plus
pour paris que marseille est quand même
ce que pour bordeaux mais le par paris
samedi à la base il ya vingt ans je
préférais paris à marseille parce qu il
m'énervait à gagner toujours trop un
[Musique]
mois je suis bordeaux entre les théâtres
recherche web on ne touche pas encore en
ligue 2 avait bientôt apte ou pas le
synthé la tuque on vous sentait quand
ils vont aller en ligue 2 faventia
favand sueur laisse les déchirent et se
revendent les abandons ont déjà
peut-être j'étais dit qu'il fallait pas
laisser n'a qu'à revenir
megueni d'à peine 15 ans
enfin call of le tf tfc 1 1 toulouse en
l2 c'est plus pauvres
non ça fait ils vont se maintenir à la
rage qui vont se maintenir ils ont un
effectif de fou en discuter
trois émissions en fait tu mets la même
équipe hier quand les été monstrueux
d'or perrin khazri cabaye m'vila hier
cinq ans et que finalement ils sont nuls
un nul son vieux c'est pas des
valérianes germain il progresse chaque
semaine il joue de moins en moins mais
il a bien joli tout ça mais je vous dis
mieux en mieux
note ceci porte à nice je rigole je suis
de cannes non mais si tu es nice pour
moi c'est mes cannes cannes bordeaux
s'est il ya toujours eu un lien
oui oui la zizou nicoud freinant aussi
vous l'avez pas récupéré frais car l'en
but
non non j'en oui il va partir parmi tous
les deux tout en tentant dispose des
trucs l'un d'eux me 8,6
[Musique]
et on vous a pris faubert non car c'est
déjà prêt à la céder
moi là dessus pour parler non moi je
suis pour jeu pour marseille wendy den
nico faubert télégénique
ouais on avait vieira qui nous a bien
tenu quelques saisons 1 là on est là je
crois qu'on est en en national quelque
chose faut qu'on monte deux fois pour
retrouver la nationale normal qu'il y
ait trois pommes menace griffonnait sont
pas vraiment vous faut prendre un
quelconque cette fois de bon peut-être
je me dirigeais torabi vrai nom can
qu'ils avaient des bons bons centres de
formation mais c'étaient mes coups
président au moment où récemment francs
donne cette l'obtenons nouste landes lui
bébé malheureusement je suis pas trop
mais ouais ça joue bien et pas libéré ça
joue pas bien et curieux serait pas mal
curieuse cette saison d'un match 4 4 3 1
non dommage car on fait quoi dommage
quand même à des recycleurs tass avait
dragué la la la la joueuse la plus
connue du l'équipe de volley sans grand
succès d'ailleurs
un match 4 [ __ ] ou quoi cet écart là
aussi des petites découvertes impossible
et 3 ouais mais je la sens pas pour les
blancs ça la chanson que vous restez tu
vas fallait pas la perdre ce geste il a
bien voulu kg ce tissage commence à
revoir des trucs fait une pause chez une
petite pause mais moi je vous revois un
peu de tahiti bon ça va en réalité pour
les planches je suis j'ai paniqué pour
rien ouais après si jamais il sait bien
c'est la structure qu'ayman al dawa
sherpa est ma place est simple si tu
fais des 5
je suis pas convaincu de ses quatre en
réalité je pense le nord sont mieux
mises en bessin tout ils veulent
préparer ainsi si la taille et le poids
de la cote
donc ne sera pas du west et il a craqué
il a été en sur-régime pour recoller au
score et un coup de mou pour f1 sa
vaquin ne s'oppose pas quand même ouf
enfin dame sa férule là il reste combien
de minutes dans la cadence est non il ya
des mains du clown triste cristaux reçu
six coups à avoir une idée électoraux 7g
katz et le matin droit enfin j'espère
fouet 5la et fausses entreprises b 5
tours b1 tomber vite
je vais à réactiver genre je prends tu
prends je fais tour cette tourbe et cinq
tours 17
d'un temps bien c'est le plus logique du
vote peut-être jeu de db6 un jour par
exemple le baromètre la structure de ton
adversaire
non moi je voulais si j'allais rentrer
sur la satire may take some en foulée
mais qui demandent nos scores qu'on
s'est écrit en gros ouais mais c'est
génial que les mecs commence à s'énerver
dans le chat à fond c'est beau donc la
ceni le taureau 3 ces deux tours d2 il a
échangé ce niveau là c'est cool ça reste
au score après je crois que si tu perds
le pndl et quand même nul je demande à
maxime
mais il me semble pour elle le serait
pas à obtenir pourquoi tu vas le terrain
pourquoi elle serait pas nulles si le
trois points de moins
il va le perdre parce que tour d un tour
d2 quelques voiles tard pour chanter 5
ouais mais quand tu prends autour de
deux tombés 2 et là je g4 d'abord h4
voilà est ce que c'est si mal un peu
juste trois ou quatre ânes ont atteint
il enferme pas là dedans et en
fabriquons sauf à y contribuer
c'est bien je déconne façon mais il ya
eu 300 cartes g5y les changements un
pion mois il change de version avec les
blancs fin donc il ya toujours un point
d'écart 1 ça je connais un peu ça vaut
quoi il reste qu il reste 17 minutes
dans la cadence à mathieu 17 minutes
puis en 2001 carpe une demi-heure en ses
positions ce sens et pète grand chose
mais il faut se méfier avec un réel lieu
à une pub france est un peu triste
on fait avec le plu en a quatre le jeu
dame prend avec l'idée g4 qui est hyper
intéressant mais ici des fois la troupe
pour défendre le veut ne semble pas tord
à 5 damas un expédient non plus puisque
là quand tu es pour pas perdre 2 je me
disais ce qu'on peut gagner plus on met
mais non non mais ça ça auxerre choix
qu'il s'inquiétait seront un jour si on
est a vraiment besoin de moi même y
aller quel point ça on peut pas tout de
suite acheté ça fait je disais ça fait
un peu les cartes blanches d'anne decis
aussi qu'un voyant tu as raison je
pensais que ça allait totalement et puis
pas vraiment
le rendit qui on va pas se mentir on a
cassé beaucoup déconcentre à un moment
je suis pas d'accord parce qu'en début
de match malgré tout c'est quand même ce
qui qui dominait qui est mené au score
largement quoi tu peux jouer autour des
1 je pense parce que prise prise prise
capteurs tels cas j'y annonçais de fond
de ces jeux les faire 1 kg ci est bien
placé après il ya quelque 5 menace crise
on l'a vu tout à l'heure ce thème je
préfère les planches les blancs mais je
me disais faire jouer les finales avec
un métro faut être sûr d'auto si tu
perds le pion on est sur deux ou non on
est toujours sûr de nous on a pas trop
mais c'était le rieur jean marc 11 kg 6
tu veux me petit peu joue pas au bénin
ouais ou 100 foot au 8e tour de l'ain
ouais crise prises quiévrain 4 jeter
truc dans l'autre sens
je voulais je tour des 7 6 6 oui c'est
marrant c'est marrant non mais c'est
vrai il faut à tout qui sait ce que
c'est parce que ça vaut mais je trouve
ça rigolo non c'est vrai que c'est pas
faux ok s'imbriquent et l autre idée 1,6
et 1,7 préserv 700 g iii yakari prend h
si c'est un f5 fera qu être un coup
aussi n'en est rien vraiment attend tour
ici cavallina droit l'a peut-être pas
con
sans quoi paris 62.5 je deviens un
portefeuille oui tu as peut-être raison
donc du coup deux tours de tout mais
trop c'est trop je peux at war iii tenir
maintenant il ya le pion aux what the
fuck même qu'un problème cette
sauvegarde n'importe quoi non excusez
moi et bien mais c'est incroyable non qu
est ce qu il veut faire peau tour d'être
reprise par endroits ils pouvaient pas
être un rêve 6h prend comprends pas trop
où les jeunes entre 11 et 3 tu dois mai
à tours 3 je comprends vraiment pas où
ils vont venir
tulasne 2006 dame jécistes tu vas faire
tourner six peut-être mais oui tu auras
pas tour des huit sur adam eve cette
annonce est mort non oui je pense que
les blancs qui s'y agrègent exister
quand même étrange non danel 6-3 cette
sale coup trop 3 eyes attristé tour des
3 donc ça c'est plus juste avant dans ok
bon ça allait je suis pour sauver le way
c'est bizarre parce qu'il a fait c'est
parti je crois qu'il ya eu des jours non
un petit peu la tam et lien est un mec
dans la diète qui dit que je le sosie du
mec de muse mais d'ici qu'on me l'a dit
plus de dix fois ce truc c'était vrai en
fait le nahd
le chanteur de muse pas tu ressembles
vermand matthew que jamais sur l'autre
jour mais matemale matthew bourne marty
cogner cornier tout quoi tu mets la mi
mai sa bellamine c'est sa tête c'était
mathieu la mafia et donc ça c'était leur
première partie il avait été mis à
l'essai ou la wii misa il refait une
partie comme ça à risque
donc ça va je vous il ya un air assez
fou ce moi je trouve pas trop alors je
vis un orphelinat de regarder ça matthew
bellamy tu dis ouais merci d'avoir je
suis obligé de regarder là tu vas pourri
le cerveau avec son truc menace toro 5,4
qu'elle cède cependant falloir qu'on
parle
ouais c'est pas faux mais le nez quand
même assez différent voilà on a me
rendrai kent où le de me pas le même
il est plus brun par contre ce mais
sinon c'est vrai que les yeux et le
sourire ya quelque chose
non non pas du tout fan non mais c'est
vraiment souvent je pense que ton est
bien supérieur au sien quant aux grandes
heures en tout tu parles est fier soit
fier de ton et mathieu cyrano mais les
blancs ou gratter à 5,1 sait plus
vraiment qui la gagne celle là c'est
indispensable et valiev sympathiser avec
les frenchis vous connaissez le thème
les gars on vous l'a déjà fait ce soir
je pense que matthew bellamy en fait
c'est la verse et là c'est la version
eco plus de mathieu corne est donc bien
je vais trois dames près de toi il n'ya
pas qu'à railleuse de puisque le terrier
cours dans 17 km 5 ya paquet et prend un
cap ce matin j'ai sept îles un jeu
qu'avait lieu aussi ce brocoli comme on
dit dans le bouchon qui a veillé h4
peut-être vous rendez quatre mois on des
quêtes cinq sauts c'est plus du genre le
mettant des chasses maxime ont répliqué
h4 sans réfléchir
non je vous le cahier premier set
peut-être nom qui est proche et 7j 7
je dis tu tombes dans les coordonner ces
derniers temps là mais je suis plus
fatigué que d'habitude à cause de
victoria probablement mais elle a dormi
la nuit dernière
elle me regarde pas même un joli truc
genre si tu les cavaliers h5 peut-être
bouffer on voit qu'ils bouffent tout en
métal double échec tu peux aller maltais
en force il va pas reprendre je sais tu
feras tour au 5e set up et cannes d2
c'est bien vrai donc dam des deux c5 et
p5 non les tours j'ai trois se gagne pas
tout seul moi tu t'en prends je souhaite
un prompt à 6 mois comprend une étude
janvier 6,6 à tous ok il revient à un
point ou wesley qui revient à mathieu je
te dis je suis encore pro reste laissé
là bas noté qu'à sa loge pour quelqu'un
que vous et c'est énervant
ouais ça c'est agaçant franchement et
non mais tu arrêtes détourna cas il va y
avoir dix étapes a besoin et pour naka
quand il ya onze ans je reste pour moi
c'est jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient plus de
hockey plus un pl c'est quoi le losc en
même temps tu as le times il reste vingt
minutes à 9 min raise the game voilà
donc ça serait bien qu'ils tournent à
plus un morceau bas ce serait l'idéal
on met ça ça va pour les noirs mais il
ya plus un pur
on n'a qu'à encore et je pensais qu'il y
avait égalité n'est pas égalité non il
ya plus simple pour mac tu dis savoir
pour le nom tu voles le vertueux ouais
c'est pas si simple
un jour j'avais regardé pendant des
heures pour etienne ça tu vas t'en
sortir non ouais c'est pas simple tu
fais des rouages et 2 h karaté c'est de
trouver du jeu de côté un genre bien
joué dans ma [ __ ]
je pensais au cou c'est sympa bref cette
thématique autour des 1 qui laisse la
colonne t'échange suite aura trois ans
un peu comme dans les attaques de
minorités l' occurrence sur la colonne
ah on me dit que le times écrit en gros
mais mathieu n'a pas toujours le
permettront me demande pas ça non
sûrement pas ça là c'est écrit en bas à
gauche parce que moi ils me montrent un
échec même le truc le plus utile de la
soirée quoi justement fait partie à bon
port mais ça ça va mal je sais rien
c'est de l'eau avec de l'eau non mais
total et b52 l'eau c'est sûr mais je
viens je le paie 5 avec les noirs
généralement des lycéens bcb six tours à
saint et que ça je me fais je fais trop
long peut-être 4 si je reviens vers
recettes ça on a un prix et ce prix ce
cas là les fuites et c'est un accident
trucks donne un code en gros c'est parti
ça ouais
et s'il doit pas échangé une française
en c5 maintenant permettre d'aller en
justice voilà
mais si tu fais tes valises ouais je
pensais de jeu baisser c'est bien pour
pas laisser un b le thème de b52 17h02
pas le laisser dans rien mais sachez que
ce genre de partie que j'ai gagné à ses
soins avec les noir et blanc sont
content content content tu leur mets un
cavalier sur 6 le roi effet parce qu il
vous poussez est en réalité tembec et
noir ça peut un jour je rentre avec toi
à trois dames à saint malo un même toit
- qui menacent fin ne peut pas prendre
ça comme un petit handicap c'est quoi
des prix bonne question je sais plus
mais un gros paquet de thunes fonda
maxime temps fou bon c'est bien joué je
pense à tour est fait pour empêcher vrai
donc si ce qui est de mon âme et sa très
bien joué il veut dame b 2
je ferai un petit coup d'oeil schisme un
câlin elle peut le faire maintenant et
jusqu'au trou je réagisse monde ce qui
va fermer je préfère artistes visuels en
mai j'ai suivi ce qu'on peut pas essayer
de gratter un thème pourtant dès le col
me pousse
bah ouais il domine vraiment la game là
il veut dans les docks et des cas je
pense hymne à la gagne est tombé 1 et le
jouer et d'aller vers le genre d'homme
c8 qui devait faire dans ma lutte un
coup pour y gagner un peu de temps dams
évidemment 6 pour entre nous oui mais
c'est logique mais je reste à rio le
fait d'enlever cette dame a dit ça comme
un gadget qui feront du kent dans le b2c
bien joué donc que ridley scott qui
prendrait que de celui d'henri iv a
prouvé qu'à attendre tout à leur arrivée
l'homme est tombé 1 il ya pas mal parce
qu'il ya eu les fusains assez bien joué
ça de chasse la dame et il veut te jouer
la finale
tu aimes bien ce style là bas c'est mon
style en fait
c'était un peu économique voient ce
qu'ils veulent s ils auront droit et
tours 4 peut-être quand même des pop up
mon champion oui c'était pour faire un
verbe haut fais gaffe à kg 6-1 pas faire
un petit tour j'ai cinq échecs l'aja
pour commencer et cavaliers cinq ans
après et a pas trop mais de 9 5 1
peut-être que tu peux faire tous rêvent
cinq ici pour f5 ici c'est pas trop de
couleurs et tous réussissent ça je
pensais que voulait pas rentrer dedans
mais tu perds passé six à la fin preuve
cette ce prix hi fi tout un chacun voit
bien les agents d'un ibook chevelu boyle
et cavaliers le cap sur france 3 qu'il y
avait des fuites main je crois qu'il est
en train de se faire maquiller la page
agca qui peut passer cloud et aux inuits
ivey
khelif 6 et 3 5
on relève trois jaunes un petit coup de
tours h3g 7
moi je suis là il ya kg 8 peut-être tour
1,8 et des 4 1
les noirs ont ce que tu as raison mais
de moins en mois chez sur jeu - sur
l'état du mardi 4 mai la suite est qu il
a sauvé sa serait affreux et bien joli
les grosses parties techniques
travaillent le score ils refaite
tellement pas le match ça au refus
tellement pas à mathieu il se fait des
chemins de la soirée s'est déchiré et
partout quoi ça c'est une déchirure
mathieu mais il résiste quoi c'est
incroyable
barret du coup c'est la dernière en
trois minutes là ouais c'est tellement
le score ils refusent tellement rien
incroyable mais sow il a quand même un
gros mental pour résister pour continuer
parce que tellement de désillusions mais
il continue il continue il continue
regarder l'air écoeuré à l'écran ouais
franchement il ya la couleur des noms
mais c'est très dur mentalement ça
allait un coup à 89,5
comment comment est-ce que ce iman pas
dans ce match franchement si la puce de
plus froid ce n'est pas un scandale et
en bullet ses shows la naca je pense
qu'en du let tu me rends pas compte
il avait fait comme maxime en mobylette
mais seuls les plus forts qu'eux enfin
il était plus fort en plus ça je crois
dans le match parce qu'un plusieurs je
pense que ça les arrange
wen oms à la range mais un gros dur
aucune chance j'imagine oui mais quoi
qu'il en soit d'un match 3 il faut y
penser
oui un plus un c'est mieux pour sow bah
c'est juste ça mais moins valeur ce qui
est très bon avec la souris un peu moins
vrai mais bon accueil que par la pac à
la souris en tout cas c'est la dernière
partie du segment mathieu nom et ses
études il est vraiment énervé bassila et
gagneuse même nul ça va au moins on aura
du spectacle jusqu'au bout et c'est une
amie l'intrant belle finale 1 mathieu
veut on a eu peur à 6 ennemis 2000
oui depuis savin on a eu un peu peur je
te cache pas on a un peu suez non il
beugle un bac à whale a réfléchi
longtemps tour 8es la partie d'avant si
nous a fait un petit bug âge comme ça
mais j'en sais que quand ils dominent
pas qu'on me donne
[Musique]
comment ça marche la tactique comme
preuve un simple et franc de 5
je crois qu'il a raté quelque chose on
regarde sa tête il l'a 6 points il faut
f4 pourquoi je suis pas venu à yale
flotte ou x 3 sahara est plus malin il
faut l'avoir vu x 3 pas vu huy hoàng 7e
f5
c'est ça que j'avais pas vu ces cinq pas
vu mais on m'a dit on sont vos passions
qui en prend 1,5 pour qu'on peut pas il
leur donne des quatre autres ogres je
pense faut aller chercher le tu peux
prendre de la tour atteint 1000 ne lave
pas grand chose ce qui amena dam des
cartes réseau k parce que sinon il ya 17
ans préside jean prat f5 je pense dam
des quatre échecs aillent voter 4 oui
mais surtout il veut que sur deux des
quatre roues à agen puis on prend 1,4 je
propose que la caf et il voulait juste
rade
c'est la partie oui je pense pas qu'ils
auraient dû refouler 2t pas moins bien
peut-être 9,5 qu'edf sinon il est pareil
je pensais qu'il y avait une option il y
en a qu'un pardon à tuer les américains
non non ça va ça va ça va ce genre de
truc qui peut même gagner alors une
minute bien joué ça il ya des principes
directeurs et amène le fond de ton cash
3 ouest il a fait ses incessantes a pas
trop le choix est laissé capte au rêve
de d'un pétrole
il est moins bien qu'un bon élève sicile
cave et prend donc là il va peut-être
jacques m6 iphone avec des quêtes
peut-être fouet f 4 1 aissaoui pouvez
dès maintenant
mais bon voilà je pense qu'au regard des
arrières fia s'est vu en l'air
c'est un cauchemar en réalité un ce que
je vous prends fait nullement ne
trompent pas 1 3 c'est triste à toi t'as
pas envie mais ce que tu as le choix
parce qu'ils avaient quatre jets je
pense qu objectivement ça doit tenir sur
un jeu parfait je suis pas sur mais bon
là on glisse avec le cavale en plus je
mettrais pas mon livre là-dessus par un
gros livre à bout ça peut pas être très
gros livre à rabat un pea plutôt coincé
un un machin épargne action là ils
appellent ça non je qui les trois
questions des fois même beckett et la
news qui a été cassée qui peut rodez a
chuté je suis tellement sueur pour moi
c'est non il faut pas jours eux trois
ils tentent de bain pour répéter des
coûts qui essaient 1 1 l'aurait péter du
coup on attend jusqu'à 34 c nul ils ne
proposent que c'est ok toi non non il
n'y avait pas moyen de faire car et
lycéens plutôt web et car il voyait
peut-être pas comme lui c'est est ce que
2 est vraiment prête à plus de 15 mhz ou
un qui a été quatre elyonor four b2 elle
fait de tels échanges fr kg 3 kf5 moulin
c'est bizarre surtemps ok donc il tourne
à plus d'un mois il devrait la refuser
et donc à nouveau une poserait même
chose si minutes
ok ok petit dessin l'hôtesse a une
petite pub les gars et à
j'ai eu une petite pub et ça reprend
dans 5 minutes mais je vais rester pour
ceux qui n'ont pas
sur un cas tout est possible mais le
match est plus serré que prévu
le match est plus serré que prévu les
mecs c'est une assez bonne nouvelle de
voir cette joie may cry seb celle qui
écrit bucquoy s'est petit à trop su avec
sa partie celle qui a trop suer
donc
donc c'est bah ouais ouais c'est ben
c'est petit michael aller boire un p'tit
coup mais je le comprends c'est pas pas
facile c'est pas facile ce qu'il a vécu
entre guillemets c'est vrai que c'est
bien c'est bien fait marcher dessus on
va dire les choses comme elles sont il a
perdu à la sortie de l'ouverture ça n'a
pas duré très longtemps
comme me dirait un certain mur tasca
savais que ça pas été ça pas été ça pas
été glorieux mais après ça arrive hein
c'est la dure vie des échecs et donc
ouais donc on va partir pour 30 minutes
mais savoure et qui va à mon avis va pas
il va pas faire le résumé de sa partie
il a en gros en gros sortie d'ouverture
il joue un coup et ses filles ont fait
peu abandonné après huit coups je pense
ça arrive ça arrive mais je pense pas
que je vais faire un résumé tea-party
l'a résumé hildur 30 secondes sur la
théorie j'ai inversé de coûts ces
perdants fini
ça arrive à tout le monde ça arrive à
tout le monde mais c'est toujours la
déception nada évidemment bien
évidemment c'est pas facile à spa fils
et de sur vivre ce genre de moments mais
bon il va il va y arriver il va y
arriver notre seb en nitrites a été
tranchée non il s'est préparé longtemps
en plus bref au look orange et ça arrive
ça m'arrivait plein de fois maintenant
ça m'arrive plus vu que j'ai arrêté de
jouer
ça permet de d'éviter que ça arrive
justement ces pratiques
non j'ai voulu faire un truc pas mal
mais je suis mis sur l'historique
instagram j'adore tellement ridicule
d'ailleurs j'ai un tennis avec fable
demain à midi faut que j'écrive
je vais écrire la fin pour lui confirmer
pendant la pause charme sont que c'est
mieux que j'écris ma sms et mes trucs
pendant la pause plutôt que vous mettre
la musique de folie et mathieu qui est
de retour y est tu penses que ce soit
encore une chance ou pas willie walsh je
regarde les résultats de cannes bahia
puissants avants budget complètement
j'écris ma femme complètement contre le
cours du match
avec complète vingtaine pas mais ouais
c'est ouais ouais donc après 13 ans dans
le froid après tactiquement l'a10 fait
retourner défaut c'est beau il fait quoi
d'ailleurs
dans son point bas là ça commence à 21h
je sais pas je me tâte et moi peut-être
après je vais le voir je peux peut-être
rentrer voir la belote ça à 30 ans à
très intéressant
j'adore la façon dont j'ai vu des tables
où il a gagné marque mais je veux contre
un autre une autre personne avec qui je
travaille depuis hier sont du coup
est-ce qu'on peut aller voir les
appariements sais mais je suis issue la
chaîne me regarde tous les trucs les all
in les all in
lewin je serai pas j'ai 23 40 80 50
il est jeune
oui vient d'avoir un enfant mais les
plus jeunes que nous sommes que moi et
peut-être que la karachi et l'anp carnet
je sais toi à moi aussi je connais
quelqu'un qui joue là que vous pourrez
entendre ton avait par contre j'ai un
pote la emile-roux rt guinn une partie
d'échecs qui n'est pas lyonnais n'a été
si l'alerté par exemple symbole un mode
board paradise toi partout
ouais non c'est puis quand même déçu
pour sa partie franchement c'est du rhin
c'est dur
ça te laisse sans voix de seconde pour
la prépa demain matin ça est hors champ
cinq minutes
non je dis que je peux pas maintenant
que je peux demain matin c'est
normalement se prépare à 13 heures il
veut pas se préparer trop le petit il a
raison non moins prépa trésor pour
partie à 15h pour samedi mais le matin
il va faire un foot c'est bien ronde du
matin demain
enfin dimanche matin je crois mais
demain c'est après que c'est physique
alors quand même le tournoi est on à 9
heures on à 15h10 pour préparer oui il
ya un peu de queue pour entrer à la
salle
oui pareil que son avis si la personne
que j'entraîne à gagner du coup à cinq
et demi dans le pays ouais bah c'est un
pied et demi sur 7
si tu finis avec 2 sur 2 tu joues encore
quelque chose
[Musique]
c'est plutôt bien s'est plutôt bien les
parties matin ne compte pas oui bah oui
bien sûr c'est la vague c st georges et
admire en équipe de france il ya ronde
du matin mais c'est un truc de fou est
dit mais ça fait cinq ans que j'ai pas
glynn parti le matin arrêté et rip
moi j'aime bien les partis le matin
quand je me lève le matin tôt tu vas
chez moi je suis très mac est leur toit
ce matin 7 heures maintenant le malade à
8 heures oui moi aussi tu as toujours à
gré entre 8h et 8h30
cette fois je rêvais plutôt mais gégé et
fut un temps j'étais un gros dormeur et
surtout un couche très tard
non mais c'est pas assez pas un bon
rythme est moins efficace quand tu fais
comme ça tarif ou non les athlètes ne
font pas ça mathieu
ses vents sua rugby ont fait les deux
parties harry veut pas analysé sa partie
aujourd'hui 500 salariés pour analyser
la partie aujourd'hui c'est un peu
spécial quand même la phase 6 mais c'est
à dire trois minutes
oui oui minutes il ya une belle
variantes
ce matin j'ai fait cet homme mais si je
dors pas la nuit qui dessinent d'or du
relais s'est pas complètement faux mais
elle a fait sa première nuit qui
ressemble ni chef ni peut-être deuxième
et d'aidé alors elle est contente
mais là elle était tellement contente
qu'elle a voulu faire le ménage sérieux
allez-y je me suis dit j'ai tellement
bien des remous y faire le ménage du
coup l'année complètement morte elle est
déjà oublié tous adorent attentes avec
la petite sa vallée heureuse
ouais on est très content mais demain ça
son adversaire démantèle le 22 à le 22
c'est beau la vie de vos livres sur
kevin hill mais qui dit y'a quoi qui
soit il était une fan page orgue
ouais ouais j'ai une fan page sur
instagram c'est un truc de ouf je le vis
pas forcément très bien honnêtement mais
que tu veux c'est comme ça c'est comme
ça
c'est la vie pourquoi ça reprend pas
j'ai pas ils doivent se dire c'est la
finale on va on baptisa à fond on va
tease à fond pour on est combien ce soir
d'ailleurs ce n'est vraiment pas en
franchement on n'est pas très nombreux
ce soir mais je ne cache pas que les
autres chaînes on pluies sont pas très
nombreuses personnes et nombreux
d'accord on est moins nombreux qu'hier
tu vois on était commun il ya on est
monté dans les 500 550 donc c'était
quand même plutôt bien si tu dis je dis
mais j'ai dit merci les gars et les
filles ça drague sa drague à fond a
tenté matin un homme marié avec une
petite matthieu jaussaud aulas mathieu
mathieu tout de suite ça joue attention
attention là ça t'a sauvé sauvé par
écart ou les sauts alors ma que ses
pulls est allé on en voit aller wesley
on est pour rester ou pas là mathieu a
laissé leur niveau reste est clairement
aller on est clairement aller que ouais
c'est remonte à plus de lacs ont
réfléchi à tout à l'heure il avait
dominé la finale il avait dominé les i'm
so avait dominé way allez on envoie dame
ses huit salles a il avait bien joué on
égalise légalisa da c'est la dernière
demi-heure du speech s 2019 en 2020
mathieu on est dans le dur fut matthieu
ballet il est bien dans la petit tour en
a 3 il va faire un petit damas huit qui
b5 au cas où vous pc latour ambiguïté on
est tranquille ans oui c'est normalement
c'est égal c'est pesé donc maintenant à
peut-être un petit bébé cinq ans qui va
c'est pas très bon quand j'avais
travaillé si les positions s'étaient
fait la remarque qu'après tu te fais
attaquer les lumbrois plus facilement
quand il fait des saints bon bah du coup
on fait part on fait autre chose il
vraiment bas je suis pas sur un mille
poissons mais il semble que c'est mieux
pour toi de faire baisser quand tu peux
ben si tu te fais confiance parce qu'ils
font comme ça moi j'ai toujours peur de
prendre b5 en fait ouais moi j'aurais pu
re manche très pétrifié de cause ouais
moi aussi mais bon ça va oui c'est
qu'ils aient pas pétrifié thoracique
pour un gamin ferrand c'est parti là
sont un peu soporifique un complètement
sa passe pas grand chose à un schisme
saint chrême ont toujours tenté de faire
h4 mais je pars en pourquoi demain si
j'aime bien ouais tu commences à
l'attaqué une pièce en un tas n'ait pas
gagné au final cette partie là c'était
celle où ils s'étaient les deux points
de cavaliers là à temps pour faire un
tas d'autres faire entrer la halle un
truc de fou y ait cinq heures et le 3
mai que tu as 3 kg schiste kg 6l tapas
qui avait cassé le pied en g2 qui est
genre tu peux plus avancer ça le vrai
jamais fait mais bon ce lot attend
beaucoup battant le tag le regarde il
est mieux au temps on a car encore et
mais qu enfin pourquoi il me ottan
encore là encore c'est la proportion oui
mais c'est par rapport à encore du des
matches précédents et qui fait qu'il est
bon bullet c'est ça on sait qu'il y en a
plein
c'est un tout c'est ce qui domine c'est
le qui doit réfléchir et senna cas qui
se retrouve nue au temps mort cela il a
prédominé so no way
un petit peu dans quand même un chouïa
c'est durant ces 5 c'est le second c'est
un peu chaud
wes chaude maintenant crise attends
attends attends attends la cgc
la macif et il ya le 6
quel qatar au fc est aussi c'est fini il
avait vite peut-être me louise y avait
rien il y avait juste rien t'as pas t'as
pas le droit de perdre ça et merci à eux
ce vieux dogme pour le switch prime mais
t'as pas le temps de perdre ça t'as pas
le droit de faire ça mathieu un an non
mais bon c'est du mulet donc tomber le
talent europe notamment
ou alors il faut qu'il aille bien plus
ses positions trouve qu'il joue plutôt
bien chaque fois non mais là je pense et
la dernière année qui dès qu'ils gagnent
un speech est là c'est plus possible
il domine plus autant qu'avant tour g1
bas ils envoient non franchement c'est
bien mathieu - vivant jeu mais c'est
bien c'est la même vitesse par le roi
non mais il est peut-être lui on peut se
sentir phocéen était mieux que de
prendre comprend 5 mg une dame en
jacques cattin cavalia un front derrière
2,1 kg 4 plutôt que simplement il est
complètement gagnant était en fait non
là c'est bien mature allez allez wesley
à l'éval chercher petit va lui marcher
dessus allez crasse le motiver le lot il
va très vite et c'est dur et demi huit
noms spoil les prix ce prix h5 attend
quand scott
mais est-ce que je peux prendre aussi
les rois g2 tu peux aussi rien faire et
ouais ouais ici cf l france 5 un jour
aucun
voilà tu ramènes leur en f3 mais tout
récents tapas de matin des caches ces
chats qui peut être tentant aussi si
c'est bon tu doubles d'abord non mais tu
forces fo prend tout à l'heure on gagne
ça non sap erp sap r ouais c'est
conseillé de tout gagner
non mais ho kelly j'en ai ma voix je
vais jouer je virage quitte le truc
c'est incroyable c'est mais je crois
qu'il serait tellement dominé il est
tellement dominé et c'est que des
petites magouilles est là franchement ça
fait mal un mathieu des sans voix la
voix se fait chier mais ok il ya encore
un peu de temps mais ouais c'est celle
d'avant il est complètement gagnant
c'est ça quand ils le déchirent complète
ouais non c'est dur c'est dur on est un
peu sans voix les amis parce qu'il ya
plus 3 tellement contre le cours du
match mais n'a k way le poste que là on
est quand même à une partie qui est plus
de matches jusqu'à + 4 serré et c'est
qu'il est maire de buhl est en ce moment
au monde c'est quand même lui voir je
pensais magnus norman je pense qu'il est
au dessus sôichi le lendemain je pense
magnus 1 2 n'a qu'à 3-1 firoud et des
jardins ouais je pense on bulle actuelle
frêche j'aime bien les deux jours après
je parle de 1.01 je parle pas du campus
1 1 1 0 et qui n'ont 0 ce que je disais
c'est je pense
magnus naka et
mais il ya un plus d'un encore plus en
plus un magnus encore plus n'a qu'a
encore plus mais peut-être encore plus
faire sans peut-être pas fuir ou 3 du
coup j'en sais rien qu'en paca et
détroit c'était lé nord sont beaucoup
mieux non mais là il est bien non enfin
f3 d'un mach 4 affaires guerre de faim à
8,1 ses protégés j'avais cru cuisine
comme conneries
manon savard il attaque la dame h4 qu'il
attaquera là ils attaquent la famille
domine tellement toutes les parties
juste en quittant une bonne bonne des
capteurs des quatre dames 6 4 3 6 7 3 7
kg 5
c'est tellement dommage d'avoir échangé
des idées 3 je trouve c'est pas sûr
qu'il ait melloul gigote pour g6 la la
c'est pour maintenant ok allez on
revient à deux points mais tu vois là
encore c'est ces îles et il a il a deux
points il est il et il est là il à
quelques encablures ali wesley à
l'émeute ou je vole comme un temps il
reste il reste 21 minutes ça va ya le
temps encore y attend allez faut retenir
c'est un peu comme un peu comme dans
l'alpe d'huez
on revient on revient à son rythme
l'équipe des victimes et a vu en fait il
y fait des petits coups comme ça de
fouine qui laisse le pion aux prises
parce qu'il ya une enfilade à la fin il
n'y a pas juste fois f4 et dame prend un
essaim pions on est fous rires cas de
9,6
un peu être mieux pour se parfaire de
tous les transferts aux achats ces trois
des quatre non médecin c'est très bien
- c'est bien jouer pour prendre la tête
reprises et euro 5
allez allez wesley snell après un petit
coup de ces trois-là de 3,5 j'aime bien
ton prend 1,5
ouais bah c'est un pion quand même moi
je l'aurais pas vu moi non plus mais je
dis j'aime bien phu dessins que c'est
fouiner à scotia dames 16 sept
je pense qu'il a eu un peu peur je
comprends qu'il faut comme ça le c3 - où
ces 4 5 ap six histoires de genre est là
pour aider maintenant f 5,6 60 ans là tu
as l'impression de rased ont quand même
avec les blancs 6 cas et lætitia d'un
match est d'amasser d'amato romain non
tout un tas par nature c'est pas toi qui
jouent en même temps faire c'est vrai et
heureusement les quatre robes et kaki
avec moi ne va pas faire nul senaka qui
fait pas nul ici ce sera donc la tour
deux cavaliers 5h quatre sets gagnants
pour les blancs normalement oui mais pas
assez il faut boss prendre keller trois
cas et les cas des trucs comme ça
enceinte très clair non c'est plus du
tout gagnant
ils menacent pas menace rien il se fait
retourner dans un truc de ouf
la perdante la c4 au prochain j'aurai
fait cinq mois j'ai quatre c3 il sait
faire ton truc de ouf
espace café royal n'est pas mauvais
juarez 2 est assez dur à mathieu web et
loti ouais ouais c'est son métier en
fait tu as l'impression c'est vous ce
que wesley vraiment faim je me répète et
je me suis répété meilleurs joueurs
d'échecs quand vote mais c'est un moins
quand même j'ai cru que non j'ai déjà eu
un câlin oui je suis d'accord avec toi
il joue mieux aux échecs mais l'autre
arnaque les deux jambes deux échecs car
je les regarde pas avoir pris là nul
c'est vrai il a senti que sa position et
ses styles un autre jeu en réalité est
de laisser le monte droit tu es tu sens
que tu es pas pas à ton aise c'est juste
un autre jeu où les évaluations sont un
peu différentes et tout et n'a qu'à est
juste plus fort là dessus a pas de débat
mais c'est un peu frustrant parce que tu
as l'impression que vos échecs qui est
vraiment un peu en dessous quoi mais bon
c'est maintenant un peu vain essayé en
dessous échec
et là il va te faire le truc ça déjà
fait leur pause et après pendant des
plombes
il a fait tout le temps ce sens là ya
pas trop de pas de schild
sera qu alain pourquoi est ce là mais
qui pourra s'en vouloir qu'à lui même
force que c'est plutôt en début de match
qu'il a way et bullet il fallait qu'il
est arrivé avec la confiance on va en
arriver avec la confiance arrive ferment
chante tout changer bah écoute et il a
une minute
non mais les bons maca pour ces trucs là
ils essaient vraiment le meilleur au
monde
j'en parle à jouer vite et avec les
cavaliers les machins rien faire et b
trop tout cas on sent que c'est à
quelqu'un qu'il ya une salle assez n'a
cassé sa position ça c'est l'inversé qui
va les chercher car ces quatre offices
ses efforts bien qu'eric arrivants c5 et
n'y a rien à dire
c'est une leçon de jeu rapide en finale
on bekkat après carrie wells et il a
défendu hier mais juste il a besoin de
tellement de temps pour pour trouver les
coûts et mathieu même job au même jeu
mais pâques et des mythes loue des
détroits des sages-femmes juste
[Musique]
incroyable
ces leçons mathieu voilà ça c'est du
bullet c'est tout ce que je connais pas
ça ouais c'est non c'est beau je dis
rien à dire je sors on regarde comme une
manie son fouet son cavalier des gestes
il n'y a pas photo entre les deux quand
ouais c'est vraiment progressé à air
dégoûté aussi c'est normal puisque
robert à ce que j'aime bien dans ces
commentaires c'est que tu sens qu'il
aime bien qu'on sache ou bien aux échecs
et que ça me saoule un peu ça robert s
bah ouais bof mais il a quand même bien
la langue ça là il a vraiment bien fait
non ils méritent ils méritent mitsui est
tellement proche mais en longues pensant
5 + 5 il a perdu le match
c'est au début du match je comprends ce
que tu es ce qui vous dire c'est qu'en 5
+ 5 qui devait gagner surtout qu'on
avait beaucoup ce qu'ils avaient
détourné à -20 ans à -2 je crois même on
dit ils étaient 1 - 1 c'est là qu'il a
gagné 2,3 prison oui on accueille fait
genre quelconque mais là il est
insupportable après c'est c'est
insupportable mais bon il mérite un
émérite y'a pas à dire ils aillent à +4
comme un gros écart juste l'endroit où
ils gagnent aux échecs c'est l'endroit
le moins
comment dire ça le moins noble quoi puis
hervé il a gagné qu'un pion
patron pro chelsea que mathieu way masi
du 10/01 sais pas d où la sa marque
peut-être ça marche les vieux maya
damage fui tf2 forcé mais à tam a passé
trois hommes jacques adam je dois me
demory fait 40 milliards de grimaces
fresneda malbouffe f2 ben ouais c'est ce
qui fait ok avec 3 pts est enfin socam
il est vrai rino 1
après même pas trop son style 1 on en
avait déjà parlé une fois dans les
vidéos mais c'est bien un très beau jeu
ça c'est gagnant mais le truc c'est que
ça va prendre des plombs mais comme il
est mené au score
l'hôtel jusqu'au bout ouais bon après je
pense alors c'est pas une critique pour
la peau j'ai pas sûr qu aig qu'il la
gagne aux échecs il les changes auraient
fait pareil mais un étaient quatre ouais
c'est bien mais c'est 6 3 6 3 en à peine
quatre à cinq départs de naka droit des
3/4 non de plus je prends pour les
parois b6 et le jeu des 5 3 des 4 c'est
bien joué très bien à temps il ya le
pion la mauvaise couleur
ouais mais bon pour ta propre à avancé
mais quand tu prends à six blocs mons 3
ça il part dans le troll ouais je veux
jouer cette finale quoi faut des 8,6 des
bon bilan obligatoire il reste onze
minutes thématiquement il ya encore la
place et encore la place mais bon va
falloir serrer la vis un truc c'est que
je pense que cette position aille
convient 100% anna k il a été
impressionnant pendant tout le match
dans ses positions là mathieu tu
comprends qu'elle prend à caser cieslak
à cesson mais c'est bien joué de la part
de nakai jouent nus lui convient très
bien et avec écran bessette déjà tb case
en france est de jakarta maintient pas
ça fait 2 ça reste je sais sa deuxième
saison qu'il ya un aussi petit écart
entre les deux joueurs
il ya dedans c'était même pu serrer le
premier match on savait dû finir il
quelque chose à peu près pareil je
m'intègre coûteront cheikh hamad à
regarder mais ouais la petite différence
c'est quoi ta impression que sow il est
pour le scénario était plutôt positif
pour sur la dernière fois il est fini
pas loin du n'importe quoi d'acteurs
locaux de ses parts c'est une vieille
partie de tennis avec les noirs qui
avaient comme ça en faire un cavalier
avec la part du fou je comprends bien ce
qu'il faut que moi je vois quand je fais
une heure trente de la partie
pédagogique chinois et jouent pendant
des heures a laissé plusieurs les
pédagogique ce que tu te mets au niveau
des gens c'est vraiment plus fatigant
non vraiment un accueil 5 bienvenus
ouais cpc pour ça c'est 3 maintenant est
bienvenu car disent ils étaient mieux
avec les noirs ça tu vois un peu je
pense c'est faire tourner direct quand
j'avais 8 ans j'ai 5 euros 5,6 kg s'est
inquiété ce qui inquiète
car c'est ça la prend bessette et
peut-être touriste si vous l'avez tous
vu c'est fou mais ce qu'il a raison
qu'est ce que c'est que ce coup tandis
qu'ils aient beaucoup même si tu faisais
échec il pouvait pas les ans et katy
avait quelques trois fourchettes à la
fin c'est bizarre non mais y avait un
chemin que la non à 5 y a rien en
fantastique fantastic
ouais c'est son métier ça il le fait à
la perfection
ouais non il est il est vraiment un
super si ça je sais poste qui joue pas
très bien
ils se rendent pas compte je crois qu'il
joue pas bien se pose au web ces gens
c'est qu'il a plusieurs vies qu'un chat
quoi certains chars vont ils à cette vie
et nakajima il y en a 14 parra pression
qu'ils aillent là il a vraiment
énormément de potentiel pour retourner
les positions qu'à sa guise et finit sa
vie oui là +4 7 minutes c'est fini réf
we saw qui pourra vraiment regretté
lahouel la portion 5 + 1 son idée s'est
prise prise au roi je suis deux fois çi
ce haut niveau de foisches ici c'est mon
avis outre statué qu'il arrive après la
bataille livrée la bataille remportée
par paris car où baala mathématiquement
c'est fini parce qu'il y aura je pense
maximum de partie après ça là
de toute façon même s'il n'a qu'à film
d'amour quoi il sera tourné la pendue
jusqu'au bout quoi mais qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait l'an prochain d'après toi
wesley pour pour pouvoir faut qu'il
s'entraîne beaucoup en soi mais bon
honnêtement je lui conseille de polfer
pas j'ai pas d'un côté il m'énerve mais
notre côté c'était quand même un très
bon jeu à un moment qu'il ya eu peur de
trop de choses qui jouait plus pour le
gain maximum
c'était un bon joueur et ouest france il
faut qu'ils travaillent les échelles je
passe à mais ce que tu pense qu'on peut
le retrouver à haut niveau wesley et
éventuellement aux candidats 2022 oui
oui 2001 il est jeune il est là depuis
longtemps mais il est encore jeune un
lac à la nage wesley tu peux ce que
quelqu'un peut nous dire peut-être
quelqu'un dans le chat n'a qu'à quitter
white ça c'est un peu moche quand même
je trouve que 4 5 3 2 est-ce que tu as
besoin de faire ça de 26 ans franchement
je suis pas sûr mathieu ne quoique faire
ce que vient de faire un écart ou 4 c 5
3 du jeu
ok je suis pas sûr qu'ils sont utiles
honnêtement ni lutte et à chaque fois
c'est ça ouais je crois que il a match
gagné à 100% il fait ça je trouve ça
franchement un peu moyen si tu le fais
tant que ton adversaire peut revenir
bon ben ok t'es courageux mais quand tu
commences à faire ça compte a gagné je
trouve que c'est un peu je trouve pas ça
très beau ça jamais été un beau
vainqueur
jusqu'à weiss et pour les abonnés ouais
mais bon qu'est sabonis pour les abonnés
mais c'est quand même une finale si tu
veux le faire pour les abonnés fait les
quand on fait le compte est à +1 mais
toi en danger le fait pas une fois que
tu as matches gagnés pour te [ __ ] de
la gueule seront adversaires
je trouve que
le faire je suis pas contre mais fait le
temps que le match est temps plein quand
le match est possiblement retour nabeul
j'aime pas trop nettement c'est mon post
rock et sobrement moins de monde non
mais il ya une minute non je suis
vraiment impressionné par la rapidité et
d4
bah oui en fait il trouve ça un peu
dommage aussi d'après ce que j'ai
compris qu'ils wiz khalifa qui trouve
qui expliquait juste la raison pour
laquelle il le faisait mais il trouve
gf100 qui trouve ça un peu dommage aussi
j'aurai un bon prix de faire 4 c 5 road
qui qui qui a dit que cette époque
khalifa c'est qu'ils qualifient bassam
et canjet à ok ben je crois que c'était
un mec connu que je crée les services qu
il fasse l'affairé inquiète comme mon
mac ça je la grave avarie dans le même
type de situation oui mais oui il a joué
une grave aussi et la grotte c'est pas 4
c 5 3 2 ça se joue quand même
mais oui à fait pareil après l'humour
chez nous non non on a un virus ils vont
quand même arriver à jouer
oui parce que j'ai bu et il y avait un
article assadi joue ce qu'il veut ben
j'ai pas là c'est quand même un peu en
manque de respect envers ceux dont je
trouve je veux un an
bah ouais y'a rien à dire désolé de
galliano et sony est plus un
non c'est gagné c'est gagné pour dakar
ont qui n 'ont qui en bullet est
vraiment vraiment trop fort on l'a dit
on le répète oui oui oui il a montré la
voie il aurait fallu prendre la rançon 5
faisant et mais moi ils n'auraient gamme
des preuves là tu veux tellement vite
bassil a été à plus de +3 pts qui
s'accrochent un peu plus et le match il
ya match très bizarre c'est catherine
9,3 au caire et h sainte anne ont même
ça suffit pas je pense qu'il n'ya pas
bon ce n'est pas loin devant notre écran
donc merci qui joue pas si mal on me
laisse l'autre ouais ouais après non il
est bien il est bien quoi qui décide
mais il se prend des peaux de banane ou
là il est seul il est censé c'est toi
qui es le 5 et 6
ils méritent de se la prendre la can et
7,5 sur calais décade je prends les
tours 6 gagner une quand m me
attention à tour oui oui je le fasse à
faire coller non c'est plus 600
d'arrêter b il est vrai fort des trois p
3 tours c'est 3 p de nom pour detroit il
voit toutes les tailles t'es sûr que
c'est gagnant ça à ce qui est sûr je
prends le blanc ça c'est sûr support
bref si ce qui est vraiment très très
bon vieux apparat par magnus ya personne
qui peut qui peut le tenir
mais qu'on ne m'accuse il dit joue mais
déjà en dans tout les cas dans six des
jeux comme magnus no way mais comme so
déjoue comptes n'a cassé jusqu'à magnus
mais leur sexe est le seul qui peut le
gagner on tourne en m'amusant
c'est ça son probable tu as trop si oui
en fait le problème c'est que j'aurais
eu la même finale que sow de fou
cavaliers contre tous cavaliers c'est
l'inversé qui se passe fait senna cas
qui va qui avait deux trois quatre
tahrir ont des desseins gp ceccacci du
coup faut pas faire un patin bassidj non
non j'ai cet échec il revient un peu il
la fouine a été la dernière mathieu
dernière puce eyeq va victoire je
donnais un truc c'était la dernière
c'était la dernière guerre fut un bon
match quand même mais bon le projet que
le bullet il a vite sans lever le
suspense dans les premières rides ami
maxime etc
3 km dans le vrai nom le bullet j'avais
dit quand j'avais dit fort et qu'il ait
plus de plus trois sauts et ce sera
chaud c'était ça ouais ça maintenant
ce test est sûre n'a qu'à trop fort bien
d'autres c'est un beau match franchement
ouest et carmi du suspense il est
remonté on faut pas oublier que leurs
physionomies nuages un moment pensé que
c'était complètement finie il est revenu
et a pris au nail menthe et ça arrive
souvent dans d'autres ports genre au
tennis tu es quand tu donnes tout pour
revenir tu craques ou non il a manqué
deux sens ouais déjà finalement cette
première partie par la deuxième partie
après la nuit rapide ouais que s'opère
que s'opèrent en étant gagnant
finalement c'est peut-être
quant à nice et un tournant du match
déjà c'était peut-être va être le
tournant du match est en réalité moscou
début début
si je me fais un métier comme un bel ami
oui je suis d'accord 49% pour moi
c'était pour moi c'était du 40,75
quelque chose comme ça qu'on 5 à la
limite si tu as envie d'être gentil mais
49 c'est n'importe quoi puisque ça va
venir expliquer sa partie non non non ça
va on va laisser sa tranquille assez
assez de déception aujourd'hui on est
beaucoup mathieu way bros wii en faites
pas vous a plu plus c'est bon en réalité
non pour ça je suis vraiment déçu en
vrai oui oui oui fond plat honnêtement
même plutôt bien mais mois après il faut
apprendre de tout ça je sais que c'est
dur ainsi le moment là mais sa gestion
du temps le h3 était quand même vraiment
rôle il faut toujours vérifier
oui et on n'est pas on n'est pas des
vacances vous calcule pas comme ça on
n'est pas des machines alors mais il m'a
écrit qu'il avait inversé penser sa
prépa crois que c'était plus on prend et
h3 après ça existe mais il a juste
envers ses ennemis tout en vert c'est
que t'as pas vérifié oui non mais je
sais c'est comme ça c'est la vie
ok mais bonne soirée à tous bonne soirée
mathieu moi je mette la petite pub et
puis je te laisse partir je mette la
petite pub et félicitations un attaquant
wayne on mais il a fait un beau match il
a fait le match qu'il fallait il a gagné
sur ses points forts bravoure à lui un
piaggio tout le monde ciao ciao mathieu
moi j'aime être la petite pub de sortie
et la partie on la verra on la verra
demain avec seb on fera le résumé des
deux seuls à faire un live pour 3
minutes
c'est un peu dommage et à moi je vais
aller je je je me paraît en fait je
voulais juste la petite pub et je vais
vous dire à abattement du coup pour le
live avec avec seb
merci d'avoir suivi ciao ciao
oh la la
deux chaises comme pour pour leur aide
pour l'interview finale merci encore